okay hello everyone well usually in this
time slot each week I do a science and
technology q a for kids and others which
I've been doing for about three years
now where I try and answer arbitrary
questions about uh Science and
Technology uh today I thought I would do
something slightly different I just
wrote a piece about chat GPT uh what's
it actually doing why does it work I
thought I would talk a bit about that
here and then throw this open for
questions and I'm happy to try and talk
about
um uh all things kind of chat GPT AI
large language models and so on uh that
I might know about
all right so
bursting onto the scene what a couple
months ago now was our friend chat GPT I
have to say it was a surprise to me that
it worked so well I'd been kind of
following the technology of neural nets
for I worked out now 43 years or so
and
there have been moments of significant
Improvement and a long periods of time
where kind of it was an interesting idea
but it wasn't clear where it was going
to go the fact that chat GPT can work as
well as it does can produce kind of
reasonable human-like essays is quite
remarkable quite unexpected I think even
unexpected to its creators
and the thing that I want to talk about
is first of all how does chat sheet BT
basically work and second of all why
does it work why is it even possible to
do what has always seemed to be kind of
a pinnacle of human kind of uh uh
intellectual achievement of you know
write that essay describing something
why is that possible I think what Chachi
PT is showing us is some things about
science and about language and about
thinking things that we kind of might
have suspected from long ago but haven't
really known and it's really showing us
a piece of sort of scientific evidence
for this
okay so what what what is chat GPT
really doing
basically the um uh the the kind of the
um uh the starting point is it is trying
to write reasonable it is trying to take
an initial piece of text that you might
give and is trying to continue that
piece of text in a reasonable human-like
way that is sort of characteristic of
typical human writing
so you give it a prompt
you say something you ask something and
it's kind of thinking to itself I've
read the whole web I've read millions of
books
how would those typically continue from
this prompt that I've been given what's
the what's the sort of the reasonable
expected continuation based on kind of
some kind of average of you know a few
billion pages from the web a few million
books and so on so that that's what it's
that's what it's always trying to do
it's always trying to uh continue from
the initial prompt that it's given it's
trying to continue in sort of a
statistically sensible way so let's say
let me uh start sharing here
um
let's say that um uh you had given it
the um you had said initially the best
thing about AI is its ability to
then chat GPT has to ask
um what's it um
what's it going to say next now what one
thing I should explain about chat gbt
that's kind of shocking when you first
hear about it is those essays that it's
writing it's writing it one word at a
time
as as it writes each word it doesn't
have a global plan about what's going to
happen it's simply saying what's the
best word to put down next based on what
I've already written and it's remarkable
that in the end one can get an essay
that sort of feels like it's coherent
and has a structure and so on but really
in a sense it's being written one word
at a time so let's say that the the
prompts have been the best thing about
AI is its ability too okay what strategy
going to do next well it's uh what it's
going to do is it's going to say well
what's what what what should the next
word be based on everything I've seen on
the web and Etc et cetera et cetera
what's the most likely next word and it
knows certain probabilities
um what it figures out our probabilities
it says learn has probability 4.5
predict 3.5 percent and so on and so
then what it will then do is to put down
the next the next word it thinks it
should put down so one strategy it could
adopt is I'll always put down the word
that has the highest probability based
on what I've seen from the web and so on
turns out
um that particular strategy of just
saying put down the thing with the
highest probability
um doesn't work very well nobody really
knows why one can have some guesses
um but it's something where if you do
that you end up getting these kind of
very flat often repetitive even
sometimes word for word repetitive kinds
of essays so it turns out and this is
typical of of what one season a kind of
a large engineering system like this
there's a certain kind of touch of
voodoo that's needed to make things work
well and one piece of that is saying
don't always take the highest
probability word take some with some
probability take a word of lower than
lower than highest probability and
there's a whole mechanism it's a usually
called its temperature parameter
temperature
um sort of by analogy with statistical
physics and so on you're kind of
jiggling things up to a certain extent
and the higher the temperature the more
you're kind of jiggling things up and
not just doing the most obvious thing of
taking the highest probability word so
it turns out a temperature parameter of
0.8 apparently seems to work best for
producing things like essays
so
okay well let's see what it what it
takes um one of the things that that's
that's nice to do is to kind of to get
some sort of concrete view of what's
going on
um we can actually
um uh start looking at um uh sort of on
on our computer what what's it doing I I
should say that this um what what I'll
talk about here is is is based on this
piece that I wrote
um that just came out a couple of days
ago
um and uh the um and I should say that
every every piece of code there is is
click to copy so if I if I click every
every picture is click to copy if I
click this I will get a piece of woven
language code that will generate that
let me go down here and start showing
you
um kind of what um
uh
um how how this really works so what
um
chat GPT in the end is um uh oops not
seeing screen
interesting oh
well okay that's ah there we go
okay well I was let me let me show you
again then what um uh
what I was showing before this is the
the piece that I wrote and I just wanted
to emphasize that every every picture
and so on that's in this piece uh has
click to copy code you just click it
paste it into a woven language Notebook
on a desktop computer or in the cloud
um and you can just run it
um okay so let's see how let's see let's
actually run uh an approximation at
least to chat GPT so open AI uh produced
a series of models over the last several
years
um and chat GPT is based on the GPT 3.5
I think model
um these models got progressively bigger
progressively more impossible to run
directly on one's local computer
um this is a small version of the chat
of the gpt2 model which is something you
can just run on your computer and it's a
part of our uh wolf neural net
repository
um and you can just uh uh pick it up
from there and um uh this this is now
the um kind of the the neural net that's
inside
um
uh a simplified version of Chachi PT and
we'll talk about what all of these
inerts really are later
but for now
um we can uh um just do something like
say let's use that model and let's have
it tell us the um the the words with the
top five probabilities
um based on uh the starting prompt uh
the best thing about AI is its ability
too so that's those are the top five
words let me let me I probably can ask
it 20 words here so let's say um let's
see these are probably sorted right we
probably want to sort these in reverse
order
um and uh uh this will now show us the
um
uh
oh I see this is this is sorting okay so
this is um
this is showing us uh these words with
different probabilities here
um
actually confused by why this didn't oh
I know I didn't I know I didn't do that
I know I didn't do that
um
let me just uh
make this do what I expect okay here we
go so this is um this is that sequence
of words
um uh uh it's now by the by the 20th
word we're getting down to keep I don't
know let's let's go just for fun let's
go find out what the 50th word was okay
so down here we're we're um uh we're
seeing words that were thought to be
less likely what does it mean to be less
likely it means that based on
essentially chat gpt's extrapolation
from what it has seen on billions of
documents on the web this is the word
which these are the words which are uh
have certain probabilities of occurring
next in that particular sentence
okay so now let's say we want to uh we
want to go on we want to say
um let's let's say we want to say the
best thing about its ability to and the
next word it might pick might be learn
but then what's the word it's going to
pick after that well we could we could
figure that out by just saying
um here let's uh let's say the next word
was learn okay then let's say that what
we would get next we'll fill in the
learn there
and we just say let's get the next top
five properties for next word okay so
the next word is from that's the most
probable next word is from so we could
say learn from and then the next most
probable word is experience all right so
let's write a piece of code that
automates that we're going to uh
nestedly apply this function that is
just taking the um the the most likely
word so to speak let's do that ten times
um and uh this is this is now the um uh
what we get this is using the the gpt2
model
um this is asking what the most likely
continuation of that piece of text is
okay so the it there there it goes
now this is this is the case where it's
always picking the most probable word as
I said before
um it uh
um it very quickly ends up
um in the in this zero temperature case
it very quickly ends up getting itself
kind of Tangled in some in some Loop
let's see if I have the example of what
it actually does in that case
um
the uh
let's see uh
yeah here we go
um
and um
this um
this is not a particularly good uh
impressive essay and it gets itself
quite quite Tangled Up
if you don't always pick the most
probable word things work much better
um so for example
um uh here are some examples of what
happens when you use this temperature to
kind of jiggle things up a bit and not
always pick the most most the word
that's estimated is most probable
um it's worth realizing that there's a I
showed you a few examples of um
um of less powerful words there's a
there's a huge spectrum of how of
different words that can occur with
progressively lower probabilities it's
kind of a a typical observation about
language that the the um which you see
here as well that the nth most common
word has probability about one over n
and that's what you see for the word
that will follow next and you also see
that in general for for words and text
okay
well
we can um uh we could ask what happens
in the zero temperature case for a um uh
let's see for for um
uh for the actual um
um uh
gpt3 model
um this is uh this is what it does for
zero temperature now one feature of this
is if you use some
um well for example uh this is a a link
to the API for open AI
um that's in our packlet repository
um if you use that link and you simply
call
um gpt3 it will because this is always
picking the most probable word it'll be
the same every time so there's no
there's no Randomness to this what
happens usually when you're picking uh
this these words with when you're
picking non when you have non-zero
temperature and you're picking words
that aren't always the most probable
word is there's a certain Randomness
that's being added and that Randomness
will cause you to get a different essay
every time and that's why if you say
regenerate this essay most likely you
will get a a different essay every time
you read every time you press that
regenerate button because it's going to
pick different random numbers to decide
which uh which of the of the words
ranked words it's going to
um it's it's going to use so this is a
typical example of a temperature 0.8
um type
um assay generated by gpt3
okay so the next big question is we've
got these probabilities
um for words and so on where do those
probabilities come from
so what I was saying is that the
probabilities are basically a reflection
of what's out there on the web
and those are the things that chat GPT
has learned from it's trying to imitate
the statistics of what it's seen all
right so let's take some simpler
examples of that let's say we're dealing
not with so traffic gbt essentially
deals with putting down words at a time
actually their their pieces of words but
we can assume for the simpler cases
they're just words
um but what if let's start off to
understand this let's start off thinking
about putting down individual letters at
a time so first question is
um if we're going to just put down
letters uh one at a time what is the um
uh with with what probability should we
put down what letter how do we work that
out okay let's pick some random text
let's pick the Wikipedia article about
cats and let's just count letters in the
Wikipedia article about cats and we see
that you know e is the winner a is the
is the runner-up t comes next
um That's So based on uh the the sample
of English text from the Wikipedia
article about cats this is what we would
think about the statistics of of
different letters let's try the
Wikipedia article about dogs
um okay we have uh probably slightly
different we have an O shows up more uh
with higher probability probably because
there's an o in the word dog and so on
but if we keep going and we we say well
what about um uh a really so that's for
these specific samples of English let's
let's keep going let's let's
um uh let's make um uh a um
let's see there we go let's um let's use
a a very large sample of English let's
say we have a few million books and we
use that as our sample of English and
ask what are the uh probabilities for
different letters in that very large
sample and we'll see what many people
will immediately know that e is the most
common letter followed by T A Etc
okay so these are our probabilities so
now let's say that we want to just start
generating uh generating text according
to those probabilities so this is um see
this is probably just yeah just um
and just fill those in oh there we go
there are the frequencies and let's just
fill in let's just have it start
generating letters this is just
generating letters
um according to the probabilities that
we get from um
uh from the occurrence of those letters
in English so that was asking it to
generate 500 letters with the correct
probabilities to correspond to English
text that's really bad English text
there but that's um uh that's that
should have the number of E's should be
about 12 the number of T's should be
about nine percent and so on okay we can
make it a little bit more like English
text by going ahead and um let's fill in
um uh let's append a certain probability
to have a space and now we can let's
let's make a bigger version of this
um and now uh this is generating
um
quotes English text with the correct
probabilities for letters and spaces and
so on
um
we can make it a little bit more
realistic by uh
um by having it be the case that um uh
the um
uh the the um
the word lengths in this case here we're
just chopping it into words by saying
there's an 18 chance that a character is
a space
which is some uh here what we're doing
is we're saying let's let's insist that
words have the correct distribution of
lengths and this is now the text that we
get where the words have the correct
distribution of length the letters have
the correct probability of occurring
with e being the most common and so on
clearly clearly not English clearly a
lose if if chat GPT was generating this
it would be a fail
um but this is something which at the
level of individual letters is
statistically correct if we said
um if we asked you know can you tell
that this isn't English by just looking
at the chances of different letters
um it would say this is English
um and and different languages for
example have different characteristic
signatures of frequencies you know if we
were to pick this or I don't know what
um you know I'm sure if we pick this for
English and we were to do the
corresponding thing for let's say which
we'd pick let's try
um Spanish here for example
um
and uh
will get slightly different uh
frequencies okay those are those are
somewhat similar but not quite the same
Okay so
that's what happens if um uh this is
sort of generating English text with the
correct single letter statistics we
could just plot the um the uh let's just
plot the um probabilities for those
individual letters oh boy more
complicated than it needed to be
um okay that's just uh
um that's just the probability for uh
each letter to occur so e is the most
common Q is very rare
Etc
in this case what we're assuming is that
every letter is sort of picked at random
independently
however in actual English we know that's
not the case for example if we've had a
queue that's been picked then with
overwhelming probability the next letter
that will occur as a u
and similarly other kinds of
combinations of letters other kinds of
two grams other kinds of pairs of
letters so we can instead of asking for
the probability of just an individual
letter we could for example say
um what's the probability for a pair of
letters
um coming together
see here we go
um so this is this is asking
um uh
this is saying given that the letter B
occurred what's the probability for the
next letter to be e so it's fairly High
the probability for the next letter to
be f is very low over here when there's
a q the the probability for next letters
is only substantial when there's a u
um as as the next letter
so that's that's what it looks like to
have
um um that that's what the um this
combination of pairs of letters the
probability is for combinations of pairs
of letters so now let's say that we try
and generate text letter at a time
um with uh not just dealing with the
individual probabilities of letters but
also the probability is a pairs of
letters okay so now we do that and um
it's going to start looking a bit more a
little bit more like real real English
text there's a couple of actual words
here like on and thee and well Tesla I
guess is a word of sorts
um and uh uh this is this is now sort of
getting a bit closer to to actual
English text because it's capturing more
of the statistics of English
we can go on instead of just dealing
with the having the correct
probabilities for individual letters
pairs of letters and so on we can go on
and say let's have the correct
probabilities for uh triples of letters
uh combinations of four letters and so
on
um the uh
and this is um
um actually this these numbers are
probably off by one because those are
really letters on their own these are
pairs of letters and so on so this is uh
six tuples of letters and we can see
that by the time you've got by the time
you're saying I want to follow the
probabilities for for six tuples of
letters we're getting complete English
words like average and so on and the
fact that that's how it finishes that's
why auto complete
um when you type on a phone or something
like that can work as well as it does
Because by the time you have AV ER
there's there's really only there's only
a limited number of words that can
follow that and so you've pretty much
determined it and and that's that's how
the probabilities work when you're
dealing with with blocks of letters
rather than rather than small numbers of
letters
okay so that's kind of the idea
um of sort of you're capturing the
statistics of letters the statistics of
sequences of letters and you're using
that to randomly generate kind of text
like things
so
let's um uh we can also do that
uh not just with probabilities of
individual letters with probabilities of
words so in English there are maybe 40
or 50 000 sort of Fairly commonly used
words and we could simply say based on
some large sample from millions of books
or something what are the probabilities
of those different words and and the
probabilities of different words have
changed over time and so on but let's
say we we say what what let's say over
the course of all books or for the
current time what are the probabilities
for all those let's say 50 000 different
words and now just start generating
sentences where we picked those words at
random
um but with the with the probabilities
that correspond to the uh
frequencies with which they occur in
sort of these samples of English text so
there's a a sentence we get by by that
method and it's a sentence where well
these words are you know occurring with
the right probability this sentence
doesn't really mean anything it's just a
collection of random words
now we can do the same thing we did with
letters instead of just saying we use a
certain probability for an individual
word we say we correctly work out the
probabilities for pairs of words based
on a sample of English text and so on we
do that it's actually a computationally
already comparatively difficult thing to
do this even for pairs of words because
we're dealing with sort of 50 000 Square
different possibilities Etc et cetera
but now let's say we start with a
particular word let's say we start with
the word cat that's our sort of uh
prompt here
um then these are sentences that are
generated with the correct probabilities
for pairs of words so we'll see things
like the book and um well throughout in
is a little bit bizarre but um
confirmation procedure I guess those are
that's a pair of words that occur
together a bunch in at least in the in
the um uh in the place where that all
this text was sampled from so this is
what you get when you're sampling text
sort of pairs of words at a time this is
kind of a very pre kind of chat GPT this
is a a very sort of super minimalist
version in which it's just dealing with
statistics of pairs of words as opposed
to the much more elaborate stuff that
it's that it's really doing now you
could say well how about to to do
something uh more like what chat GPT
does let's just instead of picking pairs
of words let's pick combinations of five
words or 20 words or 200 words you know
let's let's ask it to given the prompt
that we've specified let's ask it to add
in the next 200 words with the
probability that at the with the with
what you would expect based on what's
out there on the web
so maybe we just make a table of what's
the chance of having this three word
combination forward five word
combination okay here's the problem with
that the problem is there just isn't
enough English text that's ever been or
text of any language that's ever been
written to be able to estimate those
probabilities
in this direct way well in other words
the um by the time you're at um you know
it's the the maybe 40 000 common English
words that means the number of pairs of
words that you have to ask the
probability of is 1.6 billion the number
of triples is 60 trillion and you pretty
quickly
um end up with something where you
couldn't possibly that there just isn't
enough text that's been written in the
few billion web pages that exist and so
on to be able to sample all of those 60
trillion triples of words and say what's
the probability of each one of these
truffles by the time you get to like a
20 word essay uh you you're dealing with
the number of possibilities being more
than the number of particles in the
universe you wouldn't even be able to
record those probabilities even if you
had text you know written by sort of an
infinite collection of monkeys or
something imitating humans that was able
to do that
so
how do we deal with this how does Church
EBT
um the uh
um
it's
um uh uh how how did um
uh how does it deal with the fact that
it
um
it can't sample from the web
enough text to be able to just make a
table of all those probabilities well
the key idea which is a super old idea
in the history of science is to make a
model what is a Model A model is
something where you're kind of
summarizing data you're summarizing
things in a way where you don't have to
have every piece of data you can make
you can just have a model which allows
you to predict more data even if you
didn't immediately have it so
quintessential example very early
example of modeling was Galileo late
1500s you know trying to figure out
things about objects falling under
Gravity and you know going up the Tower
of Pisa and dropping cannonballs off
different levels on the Tower of Pisa
and saying how long does it take for
these things to hit the ground so he
could make a plot
um gosh that's remarkably complicated
way to make this plot okay
um could make a plot of uh you know I
don't know how many floors that actually
are on the Tower of Pisa but but um
imagine there were this number of flaws
you can make a plot and you could say uh
measure you know in those days by taking
his pulse or something how long did it
take for the Cannonball to hit the
ground and so this is
um as a function of what floor it was
dropped from how long it took the
Cannonball to hit the ground
so there's data about specific times for
specific flaws but what if you want to
know how long would it take for the
Cannonball to hit the ground if you were
on the the 35th floor which didn't
happen to have been explicitly measured
so this is where kind of the idea of
well let's make a model comes in and
sort of a typical thing you might do is
to say well let's just assume that it's
a straight line assume that um uh that
the the time to hit the ground is a is a
function of the of the floor and this is
this is the best straight line we can
fit through that data this allows us to
predict
um what uh uh what the time to hit the
ground from from a floor that we didn't
explicitly visit will be so essentially
this this um
this model is uh is a way of sort of
summarizing the data and summarizing
what we expect to do when we continue
from this data the reason this is going
to be relevant to us is as I mentioned
there isn't enough data to know these
probabilities for different words just
from actual text that exists so you have
to have something where you're making a
model where you're saying assume this is
sort of how things generally work this
is how we would figure out the answer
when we haven't explicitly made a
measurement
so you know we can make different models
and we'll get different results so for
example uh we could say you know here's
a here's another model that we might
pick this is a quadratic curve
um uh through these these particular
um data points now it's it's worth
realizing that there's
there's no modelist model you're always
making certain assumptions about how
things work
and in the case of these problems in
physics like dropping balls from from
towers and so on we have a pretty good
expectation that these sort of simple
mathematical models mathematical
formulas and so on are likely to be
things that will work doesn't always
happen that way you know this is another
mathematical function this is the best
version it has some parameters in this
model this is the best version of that
model for fitting this data and you can
see it's a completely crummy fit to this
data so if we assume that this is sort
of in general the way things work we
won't be able to correctly reproduce
what this what the stator is saying
um
the in the case of this model I think it
has three parameters that are trying to
fit this data and doesn't do very well
um and uh in the work chat gbt is doing
it basically has 175 billion parameters
that it's trying to fit to make a model
of human language and it's trying to
hope that when it has to estimate the
probability of something in human
language that it does better than this
that with its 175 billion parameters
that the underlying structure it's using
is such that it's going to be able to
more correctly than this for example
estimate the probabilities of things
um
so let's see all right so the next big
thing to talk about is uh doing things
like dropping balls from Towers of Pisa
and so on that's something where we've
learned over the last 300 years since
Galileo and so on that there are simple
mathematical formulas that govern those
kinds of
processes physical processes in nature
but when it comes to a task like what's
the most probable next word or some
other kind of human-like task we don't
have a simple kind of mathematics style
model so for example we might say here's
a typical human-like task we're given um
we're asked to recognize uh from an
array of from an image an array of
pixels which which digit out of the 10
possibilities is this is this one
and and so we um uh and and you know we
humans do a pretty good job of saying
well that's a four that's a two and so
on but
uh we we need to ask sort of how how do
we think about this problem so one thing
we could say is let's try and do the
thing that we were doing where we say
let's just collect the data and figure
out the answer based on collecting data
so we might say well let's let's get
ourselves a whole collection of fours
and let's just ask ourselves
um when we are presented with a
particular array of pixel values
does that array of pixel values match
one of the fours that we've got in our
sample the chance of that happening is
is incredibly small and it's clear that
we humans do something better than that
we don't it doesn't matter where the
individual pixels fell here so long as
it roughly is in the shape of the four
we're going to recognize it as a four
so the question then is
um how does that work and uh what um
what's what we found is that um uh
it's um well let's say this is using uh
this is actually using this sort of a
standard machine learning problem
um this is using a simple neural net
um to uh recognize these handwritten
digits and so we see it gets the right
answer there but if we say well what's
it really doing let's say we give it a
set of progressively more blurred digits
here
at the beginning it gets them right
then it quotes gets them wrong what does
it even mean that it gets them wrong
we know that this was a two that we put
in here and we know we just kept on
blurring that too and so we can say well
it got it wrong because we knew it was
supposed to be a two but if we sort of
zoom out and ask what's happening at a
at a broader level we say well if we
were humans looking at those images
would we conclude that that's a two or
Not by the time it gets blurred enough
we humans wouldn't even know it's a two
so to sort of assess whether the machine
is doing the right thing what we're
really asking is does it do something
more or less what what like what we
humans do
so that becomes the question is it not
we don't get to ask for these kind of
human-like tasks there's no obvious
right answer it's just does it do
something that follows what US humans do
and you know that question of of uh
what's the right answer okay for humans
we might say well up there you know most
humans would recognize that as a two If
instead we had visual systems like bees
or octopuses or something like this we
might come to completely different
conclusions once things get sort of
blurred out
um we might the question of what we
consider to be two like might be quite
different it's a very human answer that
that uh to say that that that still
looks like a two for example depends on
our visual system it's not something
where there's sort of a mathematically
precise definition of that has to be a
two
Okay so
question is how do these models how do
these models which we're using for
things like image recognition how do
they actually work the the most popular
by far and most successful at present
time uh approach to doing this is to use
neural Nets
and so okay what what what is a neural
net it's kind of an idealization of what
we think is going on in the brain what's
going on in the brain what we all have
about 100 billion neurons in our brains
which are nerve cells that have the
feature that when they get excited they
produce electrical signals maybe a
thousand times a second
um they and each nerve cell has
it's it's taking that electrical signal
and it's it has sort of wire-like
projections from the from the nerve cell
that are connecting to
um maybe a thousand maybe 10 000 other
nerve cells and so what happens in a
sort of rough approximation is that uh
you'll have electrical activity in one
nerve cell and that will kind of uh get
communicate itself to other nerve cells
and there's this whole network of nerves
that is has this elaborate pattern of
electrical con electrical activity
so
um
and roughly the way it seems to work is
that the extent to which one nerve cell
will affect others is determined by uh
sort of the the weights associated with
these different connections and so one
connection might have a very strong
positive effect on another nerve cell if
the first nerve cell is fired then it's
like it makes it very likely the next
nerve cell will fire all that connection
might be an inhibitory connection where
the if one nerve cell fires it makes it
very unlikely for the next nerve cell to
fire there's some whole combination of
these weights associated with these
different connections between nerve
cells
so you know what actually happens when
we're trying to recognize a two in an
image for example well the you know the
the light the photons from from the from
the image fall on the cells at the back
of our eye and a retina there's a
photoreceptor cells they convert that
light into electrical signals the
electrical signals
um end up going through nerves that get
to the visual cortex at the back of our
head
um and uh there's an array of of uh of
nerves that correspond to all the
different essentially pixel positions in
the image and then what's happening is
that within our brains there's this
sequence of connections they're sort of
layers of neurons that process the
electrical signals that are coming in
and eventually we get to the point where
we kind of form a thought that that
image that we're seeing in front of us
is a two and then we might say it's a
two
um but that process of sort of forming
the thought that's what we're talking
about as kind of this process of
recognition I was talking about it in
the in the actual neural Nets that we
have in brains but what is being done in
all of these models including things
like chat GPT is an idealization of that
neural net
okay so for example in um uh in the
particular neuron that we were using for
image recognition this is kind of a or
from language representation of that
neural net
um and we we're going to talk about
um not in total detail but we're going
to talk about all these pieces in here
um it's it's very kind of engineering
slash biological there's a lot of
different funky little pieces here that
go together to actually have the result
of recognizing digits and so on
uh this particular neural net was
constructed in 1998
um and it's really was done as a piece
of engineering
so
uh how do we think about the way this
neural net works
essentially that the sort of the key
idea is the idea of attractors that's an
idea that actually emerged from
mathematical physics and so on
um but it's a key idea when we when
we're thinking about neural Nets and
such like and so what what is that idea
the idea is let's say we've got all
these different um uh handwritten digits
the ones the twos Etc et cetera et
cetera what we want is if we lay all
these digits out in some way what we
want is that if we are sort of near the
ones we are kind of attracted to the one
spot if we're kind of if the thing we
have is kind of near the twos we're
attracted to the two spot it's kind of
the idea of attractors is imagine that
you have some I don't know mountainscape
or something like this and you are
you're you know you're a drop of water
that falls somewhere on the mountain you
are going to sort of roll down the
mountain until you get to this minimum
that uh is for the from your particular
part of the mountain but then there'll
be a watershed and if you're a raindrop
that falls somewhere else you'll roll
down to a different uh a different
minimum a different Lake and it's the
same kind of thing here when you move
far enough away from the thing that
looks like a one and you'll roll down
into the into the twos attractor rather
than the one's attractor that's kind of
the idea there now
Let's see we can um uh let's let's make
a kind of idealized version of this
let's say we've got a bunch of points on
the plane let's say those are coffee
shops and you say I'm always going to go
to the closest coffee shop to me well
this so-called Lauren eye diagram shows
you this this sort of the division the
watersheds between coffee shops if
you're on this side of this Watershed
you'll go to this coffee shop if you're
on that side you'll go to this coffee
shop so that that's kind of a a minimal
version of this idea of attractors all
right so let's talk about neural Nets
and the relationship to attractors
so let's take an even simpler version
let's just take these three attractors
there's the zero attractor the plus one
attract to the minus one attractor
what's going to say if we are if we fall
in this region we'll we'll have these
have coordinates X and Y coordinates so
if we're in this region here we're going
to eventually we're going to want to go
to say the result is zero we're in the
zero we're in the The Basin of the zero
attractor and um we we want to produce a
zero okay so that we can we can kind of
say
um uh we can say as a function of the
position X and Y that we start from what
output do we want to get well
um in this on this side we want to get a
one this one we want to get uh what is
that a minus one there we want to get a
zero this is the thing that we're trying
to uh we're we're trying to we're trying
to set up is something where we'll have
this this kind of behavior
okay well now let's let's pull in a
neural net so this is a a typical tiny
neural net each of these dots represents
a an artificial neuron each of these
lines represents a connection between
neurons and the kind of the the blue to
redness represents the weight associated
with that connection with blue being the
most negative red being the most
positive here and this is showing
different this is showing a neural net
with particular choices for these
weights by which one neuron affects
others
okay so how do we use this neural nut
well we feed in inputs at the top we say
those top two neurons got values 0.5 and
minus 0.8 for example interpreting that
in terms of the thing we're trying to
work with that's saying we're at
position x equals 0.5 y equals minus 0.8
in that diagram that we had drawn so now
this neural net is basically just
Computing a certain function of these
values X and Y and at each step what
it's doing is it's it's taking these
weights and it's simply taking so for
this neuron here what it's doing is it's
saying I want this weight multiplied by
this value here this weight multiplied
by this value here and then what it says
is I'm going to add those two numbers up
the numbers based on uh the the the
weights multiplied by the original
number then there's a thing we add we
add a constant offset a different offset
for for uh but we add this constant
offset and then we say we get some
number out and then the kind of the the
weird thing one does which is sort of
inspired by what seems to happen
biologically is we have some kind of
threshold in function we say for example
this is a very common one to use relu
um if that total number is less than
zero make it be not its actual value but
just zero if it's greater than zero make
it be its actual value and there are a
variety of different uh so-called
activation functions activation because
they're they're what determine what the
activity of the next neuron sort of down
the line will be based on the input to
that neuron so here again
at every step we're just collecting the
values from the neurons at the previous
layer uh multiplying by weights adding
this offset applying that activation
function relu to get this value minus
3.8 in this case and what's Happening
Here is we start off with these values
0.5 minus 0.8 we go through this whole
neural net in this particular case at
the end it comes out with value minus
one
okay what
um
uh
what does that neural net that's neural
net here the one we've just been showing
what does that do as we change those
inputs well we can plot it that's what
that neural net actually does
so as a function so remember what our
goal is to uh
every time we have a value in this
region we want to give a a zero this
region we want to give a minus one and
so on this is what that particular
neural net succeeds in doing so it
didn't quite make it to give you know
the zero one minus one values but it's
kind of close
so this is a neural net that's been kind
of uh set up to be as close as it can be
for one of that size and shape and so on
to giving us the exact function we
wanted to compute
well how do we think about what this
neural net is doing the neural net is
just Computing some mathematical
function so for the particular neuron
that I was showing if the W's are the
weights and the B's are the offsets and
so on the f is the activation function
this is the messy sort of algebraic
formula that says what the value of the
output is going to be as a function of X
and Y the values of the inputs
so now the question is well as we look
at simpler neural Nets what what kinds
of functions can we actually compute so
this is at the sort of minimum level
this is a single uh this is a neuron
here it's getting input from two other
neurons what function is it Computing
well it depends on the weights these are
the functions that get computed for
these different choices of Weights very
simple functions in all cases just these
ramps
so now we can ask well okay let's use a
slightly more sophisticated neural net
um his his still a very small neural net
this is the best it can do in
reproducing the function we want to get
slightly bigger neuron that does
slightly better and even bigger neural
net up it pretty much nailed it didn't
quite nail it right at the boundary it's
a bit confused instead of going straight
from red to blue it's got this area
where it's giving yellow and so on
um but in a first approximation this
little neural net was a pretty good
representation of the mathematical
function that we wanted to compute
and this is the same story as as what
we're doing
um
in uh
in that um uh recognition of digits
where again we've got a neural net it
happens to have I don't know what it was
I think it's about um uh 40 000 um
parameters in this particular case that
uh
um
that
that specify kind of um uh that are
doing the same kind of thing of working
out the function that goes from the
array of pixels at the beginning to
values zero through nine and so on
um
well
again we can we can ask the question uh
uh you know is it getting the right
answer well again it's it's a hard
question that's really a human level
question to to because the question
whether it put a one in the wrong place
so to speak it's a question of how we
would Define that
well we can do similar kinds of things
let's say we have other kinds of images
we might try and make a neural that
distinguishes cats from dogs and here
we're showing sort of how it
distinguishes those things and mostly
the cats are over in this corner the
dogs are over in this corner
um but you know the question of what
should it really ultimately do uh you
know what should it do if we put a dog
in a cat suit should it say that's a cat
or should it say it's a dog
um it's going to say some definite thing
the question is does it sort of agree
with what we humans would would assess
it to to be
well you know one question you might ask
is well what's this neural net doing
inside when it works out it's sort of
Katniss or its dogness and let's say we
start with um let's do this and we can
actually do the same
uh let's say we start with an image
um well maybe you know let's say we
start with an image of a cat here now we
can um uh
we can say what's going on inside the
neural net when it decides that this is
actually an image of a cat
um well what we can do normally when we
are looking at the insides of a neural
net it's really hard to tell what's
happening in the case where the neural
net corresponds to an image we can at
least at least neural Nets tend to be
set up so that they sort of preserve the
the pixel structure of the image so for
example here we can go this is just
going what is this going this is going
um uh 10 layers down no this is no this
is actually sorry this is actually going
just one layer down in the neural net
and what happens in this particular
neuron that is it takes that image of a
cat and it breaks it up into a lot of
different kind of variants of that image
now at this level we can kind of say
well it's doing things that we can sort
of recognize it's kind of looking at um
cat outlines without the background it's
trying to pull the cat out of the
background it's doing things that we can
sort of Imagine uh you know describing
in words what what's going on and in
fact many of the things that it's doing
are things that we know from studying
neurophysiology of brains are what the
first levels of visual processing and
brains actually do
by the time we're sort of deeper in the
neural net
um it's much harder to tell what's going
on let's say we go uh 10 10 layers down
in the neural net
um then uh we've got again sort of this
is in the mind of the neuron that this
is what it's thinking about to try and
decide is it a cat or a dog things have
become much more abstract
um much harder to to explicitly
recognize but that's kind of um uh what
uh sort of a representation for us of
what's happening in the kind of Mind of
the neural net and you know if we say
well what's a theory for how cat
recognition works
um it's uh
um it's not it's not clear we can have a
theory in the sense of sort of a
narrative description a simple way of
describing how does the thing tell that
it's a cat you know we we can't um uh
and if you even ask a sort of human how
do you tell we say well it's got these
pointy ears it's got this and that thing
um it's hard probably for a human to
describe how they do that recognition
and when we look inside the neural net
it's we don't get to sort of uh have a
there's no guarantee that there's a sort
of simple narrative for what it's doing
and typically there isn't
okay
so we've talked about how neural Nets
can successfully go from a cat image to
saying that's a cat this is that's a dog
how do you set the neural net up to do
that
so the way we normally write programs is
we say well I'm thinking about how
should this program work what should it
do should it first take the image of the
cat figure out does it have uh you know
what are the shape of its ears does it
have whiskers all these kinds of things
that's sort of the the typical
engineering way to make a program
um that's what people did back
15 years ago 20 years ago in trying to
make uh sort of recognize images of
things that was the typical kind of
approach was to try and recognize sort
of human explainable features of images
and so on
um to as a way to kind of recognize
things
the big idea of machine learning is you
don't have to do that instead what you
can do is just give a bunch of examples
where you say this is a cat this is a
dog and have it be the case that you
have a system which can learn from those
examples and where you just have to give
it enough examples and then when you
show it a new cat image that's never
seen before it'll correctly say that's a
cat versus that's a dog
so let's let's talk about how that how
that's actually done
um and uh what we're interested in is
can we take one of those neural Nets I
showed that the neural Nets where they
have all these weights and as you change
the weights you change the function the
neural net is Computing let's say you
have a neural net and you want to make
it compute a particular function so
let's say let's take a very simple case
let's say we have a neural net we just
want it to compute as a function of X we
wanted to compute this particular
function here
okay so let's pick a neural net there's
a there's a neural net without weights
let's fill in random weights in that
neural net for every random collection
of Weights in the neural Nets the neural
net will compute something it won't be
the function we want but the law is
compute something it'll always be the
case that when you feed in some value up
here you'll get out some value down here
and these are plots of the function that
you get by doing that
okay the the big idea is that if you do
it the right way and you can give enough
examples of
um uh
um of um uh of what function you are
trying to learn
um you will be able to progressively
tweak the weights in this neural net so
that eventually you'll get a neural net
that correctly computes this function so
again what we're doing here is this is
we're just describing if this is X
this is let's say you know G of X down
here this is the value of x up here and
this is a g of X for some function G and
that function G that we want is this
kind of uh Square wave type thing here
now in this particular case this neural
net with these weights is not Computing
the function we wanted it's Computing
this function here but as we
progressively train this neural net we
tweak the weights until eventually we
get a neural net that actually computes
the function we want this particular
case it took 10 million examples to get
to the point where we have the neural
net that we want
Okay so the um
how does this actually work how is this
actually done how does one uh as I said
at the beginning we just had we started
off the neural Nets where we had random
weights with random weights this
function X to G of X with that
particular choice of Weights is this
thing here which isn't even close to
what we wanted
so even if we have when we have examples
of functions examples of results we how
do we go from those to train the neural
rats essentially what we're doing is we
we run we say we've got this neural net
uh we say let's pick a value of x 0.2
for example let's run it through the
neural net let's see what value we get
okay we get this value here oh we say
that value is not correct based on what
we were trying to based on the training
data that we have based on this function
that we're trying to we're trying to
train the neural Nets to generate that
training it isn't the correct result uh
it should have been let's say a minus
one and it was in fact a 0.7 or
something okay so then the idea is that
knowing that we got it wrong
we we can measure how much we got it
wrong and we can do that for many
different samples we can take let's say
a thousand examples of this mapping from
value X to function G of X that the
neural net computes and we can say of
those thousand examples
um how far off were they and we can
compute what's often called the loss
which is take all those values of what
what we should have got versus what we
actually got and for example take the
sum of the squares of the differences
between those values
um and that gives us a sense of if if
all the values were right on that would
be zero but in fact it's not zero
because we didn't actually get the right
answer without knowing that and so then
what we're trying to do is to
progressively reduce that loss we're
trying to progressively tweak the neural
net so that we reduce that loss so for
example this is what it would typically
look like you you typically have this is
the loss as a function of the number of
examples you've shown and what you see
is that as you show more and more
examples the loss progressively
decreases reflecting the fact that the
the function that's being computed by
the neural net is getting closer to the
function we actually wanted and
eventually the loss is really quite
small here and then the function is
really computed by the neural net is
really close to the one we wanted that's
kind of the idea of training a neural
net we're trying to tweak the weights to
reduce the loss to to get to where we
want okay so let's say we've got a
neural that's particular form of Weights
we compute the loss
the loss is really bad it's we're pretty
far away how do we arrange to
incrementally get closer to the right
answer well we have to tweak the weights
but what direction do we tweak the
weights in okay so this is a tricky
thing that that um uh got figured out
well in the 1980s for further on that's
how to do this in a reasonably it was
known how to do this in simple cases I
should say that the the idea of neural
Nets originated in 1943
um uh Warren McCulloch and Walter Pitts
were the two guys who wrote this sort of
original paper that described these
idealized neural Nets and what's inside
chat GPT is basically a big version of
what was described in 1943 and there was
sort of a long history of people doing
things with just one layer of neural
Nets and that didn't work very well and
then early 1980s
um it uh started to be some knowledge of
how to deal with with more layers of
neural Nets and then when gpus start to
exist and computers got faster sort of
big breakthrough around 2012 where it
became possible to deal with uh sort of
training and using sort of deep neural
Nets
um by the way I for people who are
interested I did a discussion with a
friend of mine named Tara sanovsky who's
been involved with neural nets for about
45 years now and has been quite
instrumental in many of the many of the
developments that have happened I did a
discussion with him that was live
streamed a few days ago which you can
you can find on the web and so on if
you're interested in that that history
but back to back to sort of how these
things work what we want to do is we
found the loss is bad let's reduce the
loss how do we reduce the loss we need
to tweak the weights what direction do
we tweak the weights in in order to
reduce the loss
well this turns out to be a big
application of calculus because
basically what's happening is our neural
net corresponds to a function
it has it's a function of the weights
it's a function of once we when we
compute the loss we are basically
working out the value of this neural net
function for lots of values of X and Y
and so on and that object that thing
we're Computing is a big complicated we
can think of it as an algebraic formula
that we can think of as being a function
of all those weights so how do we make
the thing better how do we reduce the
overall value how do we tweak the
weights to reduce this this overall loss
quantity well we can kind of use
calculus we can kind of say we can think
of this as sort of a surface as a
function of all of these weights and we
can say we want to minimize this
function as a function of the weights so
for example we might have a in a very
simplified case well this is not good
um
in a very simplified case we might have
a
h
some as a function of just two weights
so for example in those neural Nets I
was just showing they had I don't know
15 weights or something
um in the real example of an image
recognition network it might be 40 000
weights in Chachi DT it's 175 billion
weights but here we're just looking at
two weights and we're asking if this was
the loss as a function of the value of
those weights how would we find uh the
the
um uh the minimum how would we find the
how will we find the best values of
those weights see oh there we go
um
so this is a typical procedure to use
so-called gradient descent basically
what you do is you say I'm at this
position on this lost surface lost
surface where the the coordinates of the
surface are weights what I want to do is
I want to get to a lower point on this
lost surface and I want to do that by
changing the weights always following
this gradient Vector kind of down the
hill the steepest descent down the hill
and that's something that you just have
to use calculus and you just work out
derivatives at this point as a function
of these weights and the direction where
you are finding the the maximum uh of
these derivatives you you're going down
the hill as much as you can okay so
that's that's kind of how you try to
minimize the loss is by tweaking the
weights so that you follow this gradient
descent thing to to get to the minimum
now there's a there's a bit of a bug
with this because the surface that
corresponds to all the weights it might
have as this picture shows it might have
more than one minimum and actually this
Minima might not be all at the same
height so for example if you're on a
mountain Escape there might be a
mountain lake there might be a very high
altitude Mountain Lake and all of the
water that's kind of following seepers
are sent down to get to the minimum only
manages to get to that high altitude
Mountain Lake even though there's a low
altitude Mountain Lake that will be a
much lower value of the loss so to speak
that isn't reached by this gradient
descent method it's never you you get
stuck in a local minimum you never reach
the more Global minimum and that's kind
of what uh what potentially happens in
um uh in neural Nets is you can be okay
I'm going to reduce the loss I'm going
to tweak the weights but whoops I can't
really get very far I can't reduce the
loss enough to be able to successfully
reproduce my function with my neural net
or whatever I can't tweak the weights
enough because I got stuck in a local
minimum I don't know how to get out of
that local minimum so this was a the
sort of big breakthrough in Surprise of
2012 in in the development of neural
Nets was the following Discovery you
might have thought that you'd have the
best chance of getting a neural net to
work well when it was a simple mirror on
that you kind of get your arms around it
and figure out all these weights and do
all these calculations and so on but
actually it turns out things get easier
when the neural get net and the problem
it's trying to solve gets more
complicated
and roughly the intuition seems to be
this although one didn't expect this
nobody I think expected this I I
certainly didn't didn't expect this that
um it's sort of obvious after the fact
okay the issue is
you are you going to get stuck
as you try and follow this gradient
descent well if you're in a kind of low
dimensional space
it's quite easy to get stuck you just
get into the one of these Mountain Lakes
you can't go any further but in a high
dimensional space there are many
different directions you could go and
the chances are any local minimum you
get to you'll be able to escape from
that local minimum because there'll
always be some Dimension some direction
you can go that allows you to escape and
that's what seems to be happening it's
not totally obvious it would work that
way but that's what seems to be
happening
um in in these neural Nets is there's
always sort of a when you have a
complicated enough neural net there's
always a way to escape there's always a
way to reduce the the loss and so on
okay so so that's kind of the um
uh this idea of you tweak the weights to
reduce the loss that's what's going on
in all neural Nets and you can um uh uh
there are different schemes for you know
what how you do the gradient descent and
how big the steps are and there are all
kinds of different things there are
different ways you can calculate the
loss when we're doing it for language
we're calculating probabilities of words
based or probabilities of sequences of
words based on the model versus based on
what we actually see in the data as
opposed to just distances between
numbers and so on but it's the same
basic idea
okay so when that happens
um let's see uh
we can potentially get
um uh every time we run one of these
neural Nets we do all this tweaking of
weights and so on we get something where
yes we got an ill on that that
reproduces the thing we want okay so
there these are the results from four
different neural Nets that all
successfully pretty much reproduce this
function now you might ask well what
happens if I go
um
uh
let's see what happens if I
um
yeah what happens if I go outside the
range where I had explicitly trained the
neural net I'm telling it I told it my
function X goes to G of X for this range
here the one in white but then I say
well I've got the neural net now let me
try running it for a value of x that I
never trained it for what's it going to
give well that will depend on which
particular set of choices about which
minimum which weight tweaking Etc et
cetera et cetera it went to and so when
the neural net tries to figure out
things that it wasn't explicitly trained
on it's going to give completely
different answers depending on the
details of how the neural net happened
to get trained that's it's kind of like
it knows the things which it's already
seen examples of it's kind of it's it's
going to be constrained to basically
reproduce those examples when you're
dealing with things that are kind of out
of the box
it it might think differently out of the
box so to speak depending on the details
of that neural net
all right so
let's see
this whole question about training
neural Nets is um uh
it's a it's a giant Modern Art so to
speak of how to train a neural net and
the um over the last particularly the
last decade there's been sort of
increasingly elaborate
sort of knowledge of that art of
training neural Nets and there's been a
certain amount of lore about how these
neural Nets should get trained that's
that's developed
so how does that what's what's sort of
in that law well kind of the the first
question is
um
uh you know what kind of architecture of
neural net how should you how many
neurons how many neurons at each layer
how should they be connected together
what should you use
um and uh
there have been a number of kind of
observations in sort of the art of
neural Nets that have emerged so what
was believed at the beginning was uh
every different task you want a neural
net to do you would need a different
architecture to do it you would somehow
optimize the architecture for each task
it's turned out that that hasn't that
isn't the case it's much more that you
that there are generic neural net
architectures that seem to go across a
lot of different tasks and you might say
isn't that just like what happens with
computers and you Universal computers
you need only you can run different
software on the same computer same
Hardware different software that was the
kind of idea from the 1930s that
launched the whole computer Revolution
the whole notion of software and so on
is this a repetition of that I don't
actually think so I think this is
actually something slightly different I
think that the reason that the neural
Nets the the sort of a small number of
architectures cover a lot of the tasks
neuronauts can do is because those tasks
that neural ads can do are tasks that we
humans are also pretty good at doing and
these neural Nets are kind of
reproducing something about the way we
humans do tasks and so while the tasks
you're asking the neural net to do are
tasks that are sort of human-like any
human-like neuron that is going to be
able to do those tasks now there are
other tasks that are different kinds of
computations that neural Nets and humans
are pretty bad at doing and those will
be sort of out of this zone of it
doesn't really matter what architecture
you have
well
uh okay so there are all kinds of other
things that um
um that people sort of wondered about
like they said well let's make instead
of making these very simple neurons that
were just like the ones from 1943 let's
make a more complicated Assemblies of
things and and let's put more detail
into the in internal operations of the
neural net turns out most of that stuff
doesn't seem to matter
and I think that's unsurprising from a
lot of science that I've done uh not
specifically related to neural Nets I I
think that that um
um that's a uh
um
that that's something
um that isn't too surprising now when it
comes to neural Nets and sort of how
they're architected
um there are a few features that um uh
it is useful to to sort of capture a few
features this is not the right thing
that's the right thing
um the um
uh there are a few features of um
the data that you're looking at with the
neural net that it is useful to that it
seems useful to capture in the actual
architecture of the neural net it's
probably not in the end ultimately
completely necessary it's probably the
case that you could use a much more
generic neural net and with enough
training enough enough kind of uh sort
of tweaking from the actual data you'd
be able to learn all these things but
for example if you've got a neural net
that's dealing with images it is useful
to initially arrange the neurons in an
array that's like the pixels and so this
is sort of representation for the
particular Network called the net that
we were showing uh for image Rec for for
um uh digit recognition uh this is sort
of a representation of there's a first
layer of of neurons here that sort of
thickens up into multiple multiple
different copies of the image which we
actually saw
um looking at those pictures and then it
keeps going and eventually it rearranges
what one thing about neural Nets to to
understand is that neural Nets take
everything they're dealing with and
grinds it up into numbers
computers take everything they're
dealing with and eventually grinds it up
grind it up into zeros and ones into
bits neural Nets right now are grinding
things up into uh into arbitrary numbers
you know 3.72 they're they're real
numbers not not necessarily just zeros
and ones it's not clear how important
that is it is necessary when you're
going to incrementally improve weights
and kind of use calculus-like things to
do that it's necessary to have these
continuous numbers to be able to do that
but in any case whether you're showing
the neural net a picture a piece of text
whatever in the end it's got to be
represented in terms of numbers and
that's um uh that's sort of a but but
but how those numbers are arranged like
for example here there's an array of
numbers which are sort of arranged in
the in the pixel positions and so on the
whole array is reconstituted and
rearranged and flattened and so on and
in the end you're going to get
probabilities for each of the uh each of
the ten digits that will be just a
sequence of of numbers here sort of a
rearranged collection of numbers
Okay so
let's see
right picture
there we go okay so this is um uh so
we're talking about sort of
um
uh how complicated and you're wrong that
do you need to achieve it to perform a
particular task sometimes pretty hard to
estimate that because you don't really
know how hard the task is but say you
want a neural net that plays a game well
you can compute the complete Game tree
for the game all the possible sequences
of games that could occur might be some
as a huge game tree
but if you want to get human level play
for that game you don't need to
reproduce that whole game tree if you
were going to do very systematic
computer computation and just play the
game by looking at all the possibilities
you'd need that whole game tree but or
you need to be able to go through that
whole game tree but in the case of if
you're trying to achieve sort of
human-like performance the humans might
have found some heuristic that
dramatically simplifies it and you might
need just some much simpler uh much
simpler neural net so so this is an
example of well if the neural net is way
too simple then it it doesn't have the
ability to reproduce in this case the
function we wanted but you'll see that
as the neural Nets get a bit more
complicated
um we eventually get to the point where
we can indeed reproduce the function we
wanted
all right well okay so
and and you can ask you know are there
theorems about what um uh what functions
you can reproduce with what what neural
Nets basically as soon as you have any
neurons in the middle you can at least
in principle reproduce any function but
you might need an extremely large number
of neurons to do that
um and uh uh it's also the case that
that neural net might not be trainable
it might not be the case that you can
find some for example gradient that
always makes the loss go down and so on
just by tweaking weights it might be
that that you you couldn't incrementally
get to that result
well okay so
uh oops let's say you've got
um a uh you've decided on your
architecture of your neural net and now
you want to train your neural net okay
so the next big thing is you have to
have the data to train your neural net
from and there are two basic categories
of training that one does for neural
Nets supervised learning and
unsupervised learning so in supervised
learning you give the neural net a bunch
of examples of what you want it to learn
so you might say
um here are uh 10 000 pictures of cats
10 000 pictures of dogs the pictures of
cats are all tagged as being this is a
picture of a cat dogs or there's a
picture of a dog and you're feeding the
neural net these uh these things that
are
um kind of explicit things that you want
it to learn now that that's what one has
to do for many forms of of machine
learning
um it can be non-trivial to get the data
often there are sources of data that
where you're sort of piggybacking on
something else like you might get images
from the web and they might have alt
tags that were text describing the image
and that's how you might be able to
associate the you know the description
of the image the fact this is a cat to
the actual image or you might have you
know if you're doing
um uh audio kinds of things you might
have something where you um
uh uh you might say let's get a bunch of
videos which have closed captions and
that will give us the the sort of
supervised information on here's the
audio here's the text that corresponded
with that audio that's what we have to
learn
so that's some that's sort of one style
of of uh teaching neural Nets is
supervised learning where you've got
data which explicitly is examples of
here's the input you're supposed to that
you're going to get is the output you're
supposed to give and that's great when
you can get it
um sometimes it's very very difficult to
get the um the necessary data to be able
to train the the machine Learning System
and when people say oh can you use
machine learning for this task well if
there's no training data the answer is
probably going to be no
um unless that task is something that
you can either get a sort of proxy for
that task from somewhere else or you can
or you just have to blindly hope that
something that um uh sort of was
transferred from some other domain might
might work just as when you're doing
mathematical models you might sort of
say well linear models or something
worked in these places maybe we can
blindly help their work here doesn't
doesn't tend to work that well
okay the other the other form of um
uh
no I should explain another thing about
about neural that's kind of important
which is that there's something been
very critical over the last decade or so
the notion of transfer learning so that
once you've kind of learned a certain
amount with a neural net being able to
transfer the learning that's happening
when you're on that to a new neural net
to give it a kind of Head Start is very
important now that that transfer might
be or the first neural net learned the
most important features to pick out an
image let's feed the second neural net
those most important features and Let It
Go on from there or it might be
something uh where you're using one
neural net uh to provide training data
for another neural on that so you're
making them compete against each other a
variety of other things like that that
those are actually those have different
different names the transfer learning
thing is mostly the first thing I was
talking about
Okay so
their issues about how do you get enough
training data how many times do you show
the same example to a neural net you
know it's probably a little bit like
humans for us when we memorize things
it's often useful to go back and just
re-think about that exact same example
that you were trying to memorize before
again so it is with neural Nets and the
uh there's also questions like well you
know you've got the image of a cat that
looks like this maybe you can get what
is the equivalent of another image of a
cat just by doing some simple image
processing on the first cat and it turns
out that that seems to work that notion
of data augmentation seems to work
surprisingly well even fairly simple
Transmissions are almost as good as new
in terms of providing more data
well uh
okay the the um
um
sort of a the other big
form of of um
of learning that uh learning methodology
that that one tends to use is
unsupervised learning where you don't
have to explicitly give sort of uh thing
you got as input example of output so
for example in um
in the case of
this time to keep track of of um
um yeah the um
uh in the case of something like chat
GPT there's a there's a wonderful trick
you can use let's say chat gbt's mission
is to continue a piece of text okay how
do you train it well you've just got a
whole bunch of text and you say okay you
know chat GPT Network here's the text up
to this point let's mask out the text
after that point can you predict what's
going to come what you know can you
learn to predict what happens if you
take off the mask
and that's the task that it you don't
have to explicitly give it you know
input output your your you're implicitly
able to get that just from the original
data that you've been provided so
essentially what's happening when you're
training the neural net of chat GPT is
you're saying here's all this English
text it's from billions of web pages now
look at the text up to this point and
say can you correctly predict what text
will come later okay it gets it wrong
you can say well it's it's giving it
getting it it's getting it wrong so
let's that's provides uh you know that
that means it's has a uh there's some
loss associated with that let's see if
we can tweak the weights and the neural
net to get it closer to correctly
predicting what's going to come next
so in any case the the end result of all
of this is you um make a neuron that I I
could show you neural that training in
uh um
I could show you more from language it's
very easy to train uh neural Nets to um
let's see
oh maybe I shouldn't do the spell yeah
um let's just let's just do one
so here's here's a collection of
handwritten digits
um this is what is this going to be
there's maybe 50 100 digits
uh
oh there we go so this is a a supervised
training story where where here all the
zeros and they say that that's a hundred
and zero and it says it's a zero those
are the Nines It says it's a nine okay
so let's take a random sample of um I
don't know two thousand of those
um and now we're going to use that okay
there's our random sample of two
thousand
um hundred and digit and what it was
supposed to be okay so let's take it
let's go to neural net let's say let's
try taking this Lynette neural net this
is now a um
um
an un an untrained neural net
um and now we can just say if we wanted
to we could should be able to say uh
just train that neural net
with this data there's that data there
you go
on line 32
um
let's say
uh
train this and so what's going to happen
is this is showing us the loss and this
is showing us as it's as it's being
presented with more and more of those
examples and it's being shown the same
example many many times you'll see the
losses going down and it's gradually
learning okay now now we have a trained
neural net and now we could go back to
our original collection
um of uh of digits let's close that up
um let's go back to our original
collection of digits let's pick a random
digit here let's see whether from
um let's just pick Let's just pick
another random sample here
um
let's pick five examples there from um
oh I should have not called it to do
that okay there we go so now we can take
this trained neural net here's our
trained neural net and let's take the
train neural net and let's feed it that
particular nine there now remember we
only trained it on 2 000 examples so it
didn't have very much training but oops
I shouldn't have done that I should have
just used that okay
um
okay it successfully told us it was a
nine that's kind of what it looks like
to train this is you know wolfen
language version of training a neural
net this was a super simple neural that
with only two thousand examples
um but that's kind of what it looks like
to do that um do that training
okay
so
uh
let's see the um
the thing with with chat GPT is that
your
um well let's let's you know we can we
can keep going and talk about the
training of of of of that but let's
um
before we get to training of of chat GPT
I'm going to talk about one more thing
which is we need to talk about uh this
question of kind of
well let's see do we really need to talk
about this yeah I would probably talk
about this the question of how you
represent uh kind of things like words
with numbers
so let's say we are going to have um
we're
we've got all these words and we could
just number every word in English we
could say apple is 75 pair is 43 Etc et
cetera et cetera
um but there's more useful ways to label
words in English by numbers
and the more useful way is to get
collections of numbers that have the
property that words with nearby meanings
have nearby collections of numbers so
it's as if we're replacing every word
somewhere in some meaning space and
we're trying to set it up so that words
will have a position and meaning space
with the property that if two words are
nearby and meaning space they must mean
close to the same thing so here for
example are a collection of words laid
out in one of these meaning spaces
um sort of actual meaning spaces like
the one used by Chachi pitia like uh
what is that one it's probably 12 000
dimensional maybe
um this one here is just two-dimensional
we're just putting things like dog and
cat alligator crocodile and then a bunch
of fruits here and what the main thing
to notice about this is that
things with similar meanings like
alligator and crocodile wind up nearby
in this meaning space and you know Peach
and apricot wind up nearby in meaning
space so in other words we're
representing these words by collections
of numbers in this case just pairs of
numbers just coordinates which have the
property that those coordinates are some
kind of representation of the meaning of
these words
so
and we can do the same thing when it
comes to images for example we could ask
whether
um when we looked at and that's exactly
what we had when we were looking at um a
picture like this we're sort of laying
out different handwritten digits in some
kind of uh meaning of the of the
handwritten digit space where in that
meaning space the one the ones that mean
one were over here the ones that mean
three were over here and so on so a
question is how do you find how do you
actually uh generate coordinates that
represent the so-called embeddings of of
things so that when they're sort of
nearby in meaning they will have nearby
coordinates okay so there's a number of
neat tricks that are used to do this
so a typical kind of setup is
um imagine we have this is just a
representation of the neural net that we
use to recognize digits it has these
multiple layers each one there's just
Little Wolf and language representation
of that
um
what actually does this network do well
in the end what it's doing is it's
taking that collection of pixels at the
beginning and in the end what it's doing
is it's Computing
um what are the probabilities for a
particular configuration it's got It's
going to produce a collection of numbers
at the end because remember neural nets
all they ever deal with are collections
of numbers so what it's going to do is
it's going to produce a collection of
numbers at the end where uh each
position in this collection of numbers
there'll be 10 numbers here each
position is the probability that the
thing that the neural net was shown
corresponded to a zero or one a two or
three or four
so what you see here is the numbers are
absurdly small except in the case of
four so we can then deduce from this
immediately okay that image was was
supposed to be a four so this is kind of
the output of the neural net as this
collection probabilities where in this
particular case it was really certain
that the thing is a four so that's what
we deduce
now
the the thing we can do is we say well
let's let's back up one layer in the
neural net before we get to that that um
let's just say before we had there's a
there's a layer that kind of tries to
tries to make the neuron that actually
make a decision it's I think it's a soft
Max layer
um that uh is um is at the end that's
trying to sort of force the decision
it's trying to exponentially pull apart
these numbers so that the big number
gets bigger and the small numbers get
smaller okay but one layer before those
numbers are a bit more sober in size
before it's been sort of torn apart to
make a decision those numbers are much
more sober in size and these numbers at
this layer give some pretty decent
indication of of the fullness of what
we're seeing they this has more
information about what that thing that
was showing actually is and we can think
about these numbers as giving some kind
of signature some kind of uh
um some some kind of trace of what kind
kind of a thing we were seeing this is
sort of
specifying in some sense features of
what we were seeing that later on we'll
just decide that's a four but all these
other sort of subsidiary numbers are are
already useful we go back so you know
this is um we can Define these feature
vectors that represent this is kind of
the a feature Vector representing that
image there that's the feature
representing this image here and we see
that yeah these the the features for
different fours these vectors will be a
little bit different
um but they're dramatically different
between a four and an eight but we can
use these these vectors to represent
kind of uh the the important aspects of
of this four here for it for instance
and if we go back a couple more layers
in that neural net it turns out we can
get an array of like 500 numbers that
are a pretty good representation a
pretty good sort of feature signature of
of any of these images and we do the
same thing for pictures of cats and dogs
we can get this kind of signature of
what what the sort of feature Vector
associated with what is important about
that image and then we can take those
those feature vectors and we can say
let's let's um let's lay things out
according to different values and those
feature vectors and then we'll get this
kind of um uh embedding in in the case
of what we can think of as some kind of
meaning space in the case of words if we
look at the raw
um
uh yeah so so how do we do that for
words well the idea is uh just like for
the for for getting sort of a a a
feature Vector associated with like
let's say images we have a task like
we're trying to recognize digits and
then we back up from the from the final
answer we're training a neural net to do
that task but what we end up doing is we
back up from that final we we nailed the
task and we say what was the thing that
was just before you you managed to nail
the task that's our representation of
the relevant features of the thing well
you can do the same thing for words so
for example if we say the blank cat
and we then ask in in our training data
what is that blank likely to be
um the you know is it black is it white
whatever else
um that we could try and make a network
that predicts what is that intermediate
word likely to be what are the
probabilities for that intermediate work
we can train a network to be good at
predicting the probabilities for
Blackness whiteness versus whatever
other tabbiness for cats or whatever it
is
um and uh
once we've got that we can then back up
from the final answer and say let's look
at the innards of the network and let's
see what it had done as it got towards
coming up with that final result that
thing we get right before it gets to a
little bit before it gets to the final
result that will be a good
representation of features that were
important about those words and that's
how we can then deduce what um we can
deduce these sort of feature vectors for
words
so
um in the case of gpt2 for example
um we can we can compute those feature
vectors they are extremely uninformative
when we look at them in the full feature
vectors uh if we what is more
informative is we sort of project these
feature vectors down to a smaller number
of Dimensions we'll discover that the
cat one is closer to the dog one
probably than it is to the chair one but
that's that's kind of so what what what
chat GPT is doing when it deals with
words is it uh
it's it's always representing them using
these feature vectors that um using this
kind of embedding that turns them into
these collections of numbers that have
the property that nearby words are have
have similar representations actually
I'm I'm getting a little bit ahead of
myself there because because the the
way chat GPT works it uses these kinds
of embeddings but it does so for for
whole chunks of text rather than for
individual words we'll get there
okay
so I think we're we're getting on
getting on fairly well here
um
how about the actuality of of of chat
GPT well it's ignoring that millions of
neurons
uh 175 billion connections between them
and uh what is its basic architecture
um
the uh
it's uh the sort of a big idea that
actually came out of language
translation networks where the task was
start from English end up with French or
whatever else was this idea of what are
called Transformers it's an architecture
of neural Nets that were more
complicated architectures used before
there's actually a simpler one
um and the notion is as I mentioned when
one's dealing with images it's
convenient to have these neurons kind of
attached to pixels at least to sort of
laid out in a kind of uh which pixel is
next to which pixel kind of way there's
a so-called convolutional neural Nets or
convenants are the the typical things
that are used there in the case of
language what Transformers do is they
are dealing with the fact that language
is in a sequence and with a convene for
an image one saying there's this pixel
here what it what's happening in the
neighboring nearby pixels in the image
in a Transformer what one's doing is one
saying this is here's a word let's look
at the preceding words let's look at the
words that came before this word and in
particular let's pay attention
differently to different ones of those
words
so
I mean this gets this gets quite
elaborate in engineeringly quite quickly
um and uh uh you know it's it's very
typical of a sophisticated engineering
system that there's lots of detail here
and I'm not going to go into much of
that detail but but um this is a piece
of the um uh this is sort of the in a
sense the front end of of okay so
remember what is chat GPT ultimately
doing it's a neural net whose goal is to
continue a piece of text so it's gonna
it's gonna essentially ingest the piece
of text so far reading in each token of
the text the tokens are either words or
pieces of words like things like the ing
at the end of a word might be a separate
token they're they're sort of convenient
pieces of words they're about 50 000
different possible tokens it's reading
through the text The Prompt that you
wrote the text that it's generated so
far it's reading through all of those
things it is then going to generate uh
it's it's it's
then going to its goal is to then
continue that text in particular it's
going to tell you every time you run
through this whole neural net it's going
to give you one new token it's going to
tell you what the next token should be
or what the probabilities for different
choices of the next token should be so
one piece of this is the embedding uh
part where what's happening is it's
reading a token and it is doing I mean
this is just uh you know it's it gets
into a lot of detail here so for example
let's say that the the sequence we were
reading was hello hello hello hello
hello bye bye bye bye bye this is
showing the resulting
um this is showing the embeddings that
you get
okay this this is showing you're trying
to represent I said before we were
talking about embeddings for words now
we're talking about embeddings for whole
chunks of text and we're asking what is
the sequence of numbers that should
represent that collection of that piece
of text
and the way you set that up I mean again
this is this is getting pretty deep into
the entrails of the creature
um and uh
uh
well what what what what
you can think of is there are are
different components to this embedding
vector and
let's see what am I doing here this this
picture is showing across the page it's
showing the contribution from each word
and down the page it's showing the
different uh different pieces of the
feature Vector that are being built up
and the way it works is to it takes each
word and it has
um it then
the position of the word is encoded by a
um uh you could just encode it by saying
the binary the the position of the word
as a binary digit that says is word
number seven it's you know zero zero
zero one one or something but that
doesn't work as well as essentially
learning this sort of random looking
collection of things which are
essentially position tags for Words
anyway the end result is you're going to
make this thing that represents the um
uh uh where you have both
where each level is a different sort of
feature associated with each of these
words and uh that's that's the thing
that's going to be fed into the next
level of the of the neural net
okay so the next big piece is
so-called attention Block in which
I I don't know how much this is worth
explaining I talk about this a bit more
in the in the thing that I wrote but
essentially what's happening is
the
in the end it's just a great big neural
net but that neural net
has
doesn't have every possible connection
in it it has connections for example
only connections that look back in the
that look to places that were earlier in
that text and the it it is in a sense
concentrating differently on different
parts of that text and you can you can
make a picture here of the amount of
attention that it is paying and by
attention I mean it's literally the
number the the the the the the size of
effectively the weights that it's that
it's using
to uh with which it is waiting different
parts of the sequence that came in and
the way it works I think for um for gpt3
what it does is it um
uh
so first of all it has this embedding
Vector which for gpt3 is about is 12 288
um I don't know why it's that particular
oh I do know why it's that number it's
multiples of things
um long and uh uh
it's
taking
it's trying to put together
a an embedding Vector to represent the
text so far in which it has had
contributions from words at different
positions and it's it's sort of it's
figured out how much contribution it
should get from words at each different
position
um
well okay so it does that then it feeds
the whole thing to a
a layer of neural Nets where sort of it
has some uh it's a
um what is it it's a a 12 000 by 12 000
array
um which specifies what where there are
12 000 by 12 000 weights which specify
for each incoming neuron each each
neuron that's incoming has this weight
to this outgoing neuron and the result
is you get this whole assembly of
Weights which looks like nothing in
particular this is uh but these are
weights that have been learned by by
chat GPT to be useful for its task of
continuing text and you know you can
play little games you can you can try
and visualize those weights by kind of
making moving averages
um and you can kind of see that the
weights sort of roughly are kind of like
randomly chosen but this is kind of
showing you a little bit of the detail
inside that Randomness and in a sense
you can think of this as being sort of a
view into the brain of the of chat GPT
of showing you at the level of these
individual weights that are in this
neural net
um what what its representation of human
languages write down the level you know
it's kind of like you take apart a
computer and you look at individual bits
inside the CPU
um this is kind of the same sort of
thing thing for the representation that
chat GPT has of language and turns out
there isn't just one of these attention
layers okay what happens is the the
different elements of the feature Vector
for the text
get
there are different blocks of that
feature Vector that gets separated out
and handled differently nobody really
knows what the interpretation of those
blocks is it's just been found to be a
good thing to do to not treat the whole
feature Vector the same but to break it
into blocks and treat blocks of pieces
in that feature Vector differently maybe
there's an interpretation of one piece
of that feature Vector that this is I
don't know words that are about motion
or something it won't be anything like
that it won't be anything as human
understandable as that it's kind of like
a human genome or something it's all all
the traits are all mixed up in the
specification it's or it's like what um
uh it's it's not something where we can
easily have a sort of narrative
description of what's going on but
what's been found is that you break this
kind of feature Vector of of features of
the text up and you have these separate
attention heads that um have this sort
of re-weighting process going on for
each one you do that and this is where
you know this is like it's crazy that
things like this work but um you do that
let's see 96 times for for chat GPT
you're making you're doing the same
process 96 times over and uh this is for
gpt2 the simpler version this is kind of
a representation of the of of of the the
things that come out of these attention
layers
um attention blocks what the uh what the
sort of Weights that were used there
were and you know these may look there
there is some regularity I don't know
what it means but if you look at the the
size of the weights they're not
perfectly for some layers they're
gaussian distributed for some layers
they're not I have no idea what the
significance of that is it's just a
feature of what um uh what chat GPT
learned as it was trying to understand
human language from from the web
um
so
okay
the um
uh
so again there's you know we've talked
about kind of what the the
uh in in the end that what's happening
is it's just a great big neural net and
it's being it's being trained from it
we're trying to deduce the weights for
the neural net by showing it a whole
bunch of text and saying uh what weights
do you have to have in the neural net so
that the
um
uh so that the
continuation of the text will have the
right probabilities for what word comes
next that's its goal
so how uh and so
I've sort of described the outline of
how that's done
um in the end one has to feed it the
reason it's sort of even possible to do
this is that there's a lot of training
data to feed it so it's been fed a
significant fraction of what's on the
web there are Maybe
I don't know depends how you describe
this but there are maybe six billion
maybe 10 billion uh kind of reasonably
human written pages on the web where
humans actually typed that stuff it
wasn't mostly machine generated et
cetera et cetera et cetera that's on the
publicly visible web not having programs
go in and not not selecting lots of
different things and seeing what you get
that's just kind of raw what's on the
web page maybe there's 10 maybe 100
times as much as that
um if you were able to make selections
to drill down to go into internal web
pages things like this but so you've got
something like um some you know some
number of billions of human written
pages and uh there's a convenient
collection called common crawl that's
got where but where one goes where where
uh it's um
you know start from one web page you
follow all the links you collect all
those pages you keep going just
following links following links until
you've until you've visited all the
connected parts of the web but um the
result of this is there's a trillion
words of text that you can readily get
from uh from a web
um they're also they're probably 100
million books that have been published
maybe 100 I think the best estimate
maybe 130 million books that have been
published of which five or ten million
exist in digitized form and you can use
those as a training data as well and
that's another 100 billion or so uh
words of of of of text so you've got
trillion-ish words of text and that's
what um uh and there's probably much
more than that in if you have the um uh
the transcriptions of videos and things
like this you know for me personally
I've kind of been um uh you know as a
kind of a a personal estimate of these
things I I really realized that um
the things I've written over my lifetime
constituted about three million words
the um the emails I've sent over the
last 30 years are another 15 million
words and the total uh number of uh
words I've typed is around 50 million
um interestingly in the live streams
I've done just in the last couple of
years I have
spoken another 10 million words so it
gives a sense of what you know human
output is what but the main point is
there's a trillion words available on on
that you can use to train a neural net
to be able to do this task of of
continuing from from things
um
it's uh
let's see
in
um
right so so the actual process of um uh
one thing to understand about training a
neural net
that's sort of a question
okay there's a there's a question when
we looked at those functions before and
we said how many neurons do we have to
have to represent this function well how
many training examples do we have to
give to get the the neural net trained
to represent that function in those
cases we didn't need very big neural
Nets we needed a lot of training
examples there's all kinds of effort to
understand how many training examples do
you actually need how big a neural net
do you actually need to to uh do
something like do this text translation
uh uh thing well well it's not really
known but uh you know with 175 billion
weights the sort of the surprise is that
chat gbt does pretty well now you can
ask the question
um what um
what's the uh
uh how much training does it need
um and uh how many times does it have to
be shown those trillion words what's the
relationship between the trillion words
and the number of Weights in the in the
um in the network and it seems to be the
case that for text
um that sort of the number of Weights in
the network is sort of comparable to the
number of training examples you sort of
show it the training examples about once
if you show it too many times it
actually gets worse in its performance
it's very different from what happens
when you're training for mathematical
functions and things like this
um but uh one of the things that's
that's an issue is that if you're every
time then I should say every every time
I should explain by the way that the the
the every time the neural net runs
what's happening is you're giving it
in the case of chat GPT you're giving it
this collection of numbers that
represents the text it's gotten so far
and then
that collection numbers is the input to
the neural net then you sort of Ripple
through the neural net layer after layer
after layer it's got about 400 layers
um sort of core layers
um it ripples through all those layers
and then at the end you get some array
of numbers that array of numbers
actually are probabilities for each of
the 50 000 possible words in English
um and that
uh based on that it then picks to the
next word
but so the main operation of chat GPT is
a very just straight through you know
you've got this text so far given that
percolate through this network say what
the next result should be it's very cut
it just runs through one time
it's actually very different from the
way computers tend to work for other
purposes most non-trivial computations
you're taking the same piece of of of of
sort of computational material the same
piece of data and you compute on it over
and over and over again in sort of
simple models of computation like Turing
machines that's what's happening all the
time that's what's happening that's what
makes computers able to do the
non-trivial things computers do or that
is that they are taking uh sort of maybe
a small number of pieces of data and
they're just re reprocessing things over
and over again what's happening in
something like chat GPT is you've got
this big Network you just percolate
through it once for every token the only
sense in which there's any feedback is
that once you get an output you add that
token to the input that you feed it on
the next step so it's kind of an outer
loop where you're giving feedback by
adding tokens to the text then that
percolates through then you get another
token that percolates through so it's a
very it's a very big Outer Loop it's
probably the case certainly in computers
in in lots of non-trivial computations
that we do there are lots of inside
Loops that are happening quite possibly
in the brain there are inside Loops that
are happening as well but the model that
we have in chat GPT is this kind of just
percolate through once kind of model
with a very complicated network but it's
just percolating through once
so that's that's how it works but but
one of the things that's tricky is that
um every time it percolates through it
has to it has to use every single one of
those weights so every token the chat is
producing it's essentially doing 175
billion mathematical operations to to
see how to use each of those weights to
compute the results most likely that's
not necessary actually but we don't know
how to how to get do any better than
that right now but that's what it's
doing so every time if it has it's
percolating through doing that well
the when you train chat GPT and you are
sort of uh you're working out you know
how do you deal with oh making the
weights change based on the loss that's
another you're kind of every time you
you make a training step you're having
to kind of do a reverse version of that
um of that forward so-called inference
process it turns out that reverse
process isn't that much more expensive
than the forward process but you have to
do it a whole lot of times in the
training so typically if you have a
model of size n roughly for text it
seems like you need about N squared
amount of computational effort to do the
training and N is pretty big for the
case when you're dealing with uh sort of
language and things of the size of chat
gbt and so the training process that
that just a little bit mathematical
square is a is a really big deal and it
means that you're you know to spend
hundreds of Millions of dollars
potentially on doing the training with
current gpus and things like this is is
what you have to think about doing based
on the current model of how neural Nets
work now I mean I have to say that that
there's a lot of aspects of the current
model that probably aren't the final
model
um and you know we can plainly see that
there are big differences between for
example things the brain manages to do
for example one big difference is most
of the time when you're training a
neural net most of the uh the the memory
and the the the you're doing that by
having you have a bunch of of of things
in memory and you have some computation
that's going on but the things that are
in memory are mostly idle most of the
time and there's just a little bit of
computation that's going on in brains
every one of our neurons is both a place
that stores memory and a place that
computes it's a different kind of setup
and we don't know how to do neural Nets
training there are various things that
have been looked at from the distant
past actually about how to do this even
from the 1940s people were starting to
think about sort of distributed ways to
to do learning and neural Nets but
that's not something that's that's
landed yet as a thing we can do
okay case of chat GPT
um an important
thing was and this was something you
know six months ago a year ago there
were kind of uh early versions of of the
GPT family uh text completion systems
and so on and they were kind of the text
they produced was only so so
um and um
then something was done by openai uh
with that GPT which was that there was
an additional step a reinforcement
learning training step that was was done
where essentially what was done was
humans
told Chachi PT go and make an essay go
and be be a chat bot you know have a
conversation with me and the humans
rated what came out and said but that's
terrible that's better that's terrible
Etc et cetera et cetera and the thing
that was done
was then that that little bit of poking
turns out to have had it seems to have
had a very big effect that little bit of
kind of human guidance of yes you got
the thing from the statistics of the web
now when you look at what you got this
direction you're going in is a bad
direction to go and it's going to lead
to a really boring essay or whatever
else
um and so that kind of and by the way
there's a place where where a lot of
kind of complication about well what do
the humans really think the the network
should be that the system should be
producing if the humans say we really
don't want you to talk about this we
really don't want you to talk about that
that's the place that gets injected is
in this is in this reinforcement
learning step uh at the end
um and but what you do is for example is
uh given that sort of the way the humans
poked at those essays you can watch what
they did when they poked at those essays
and rated what happened and so on and
you you can try and machine learn that
set of things that the humans did then
you can use that to provide much more
training data to then retrain a piece of
of this do retraining of the network to
based on the sort of the tweaking that
the humans did you can do sort of
fine-tuning of this network based on the
the particular poking that the humans
did turned into another Network that can
then be used to do the training to
produce the examples to do the training
of of the of the main Network
so
that's a thing that seems to have had a
big effect on the actual sort of human
perception of what happens in in um in
in church of PT and I think um uh the
other thing that is a um
um sort of a surprise is that you can
give it these long prompts in which you
tell it all kinds of things and it will
then sort of make use of that in a
rather human kind of way in generating
the text that comes later
okay
big question is how come this works why
is it that a thing with only you know
100 billion or so weights or something
can reproduce this sort of amazing thing
that seems to require all of the sort of
depth of human thinking and and brains
and things like that human language how
does that manage to work
and I think the um
uh the key thing to realize is what it's
really telling us is a science fact it's
telling us there's more regularity in
human language than they thought than we
thought there was it's telling us that
this this thing that's that is human
language has a lot of structure in it
and what it's done is it's learned a
bunch of that structure and it's learned
structure that we never even really
noticed was there and that's what's
allowing it to generate these kind of
plausible pieces of text that are you
know that are making use of the
structure we know so we know certain
kinds of structure that exists in
language we know the um so for example
um
um here's an example so one one piece of
structure that we know
um share this again
um
one piece of structure we know is
grammatical syntax
um
the the uh syntactic grammar we know
that that sentences aren't random
jumbles of words sentences are made up
with nouns in particular places verbs in
particular places and we can represent
that by a parse Tree in which we say you
know here's the whole sentence there's a
noun phrase a verb phrase another noun
phrase these are broken down in certain
ways this is the parse tree and there
are certain the in order for this to be
a grammatically correct sentence this
has there are only certain possible
forms of parse tree that correspond to a
grammatically correct sentence so this
is a regularity of language that we've
known for a couple of thousand years
it's only really been codified uh it was
a big effort to codified in 1956
um but it was sort of knowing this
general idea was was known for a long
time
um but uh then
this um
um that that we can kind of represent
the sort of uh syntactic grammar of
language by these kinds of rules that
say you can put nouns only together with
verbs in this way and that way and to
any set of rules and this has been a big
source of controversy and Linguistics
that any set of rules you can Define
there'll always be some weird exception
where people typically say this rather
than that but if you you know it's at
the much like happens in typical machine
learning you know if you're interested
in the 95 result then there are just
rigid rules and there are a few
exceptions here and there okay so that's
one form of regularity that we know
exists in language is is this some uh
syntactic
um regularity now what one thing we can
do we can ask for sort of um uh chat GPT
has effectively implicitly learned
this
um
syntactic grammar nobody ever told it
verbs and nouns go this way and that way
it implicitly learned it by virtue of
seeing a trillion words of text on the
web which all have these properties and
when it's saying well what are the
typical words that follow well it's
going to be words that followed in the
in the examples it had and those will
follow mostly correct grammar now we can
we can take a simpler version of this we
can just understand what's going on we
can take a very very trivial grammar we
can take a grammar that's just a
parenthesis just open and close
parentheses and something is
grammatically correct if we open
parentheses and they always eventually
close and this is a parse tree for a um
uh for a parenthesis uh you know open
open open close open close Etc et cetera
Etc this is the parse tree that sort of
shows how you can
it's a representation of of of uh of the
sort of the the um the parsing of this
sequence of of open and closed
parentheses okay so we might say well
can we train a neural net to what would
it take to train a neural net to know
even this particular kind of syntactic
grammar
so we looked at a simple how big was it
it was um
pretty small uh okay we made it a
Transformer net with eight heads and
length 128
so um uh but but our thing was a was a
lot simpler than than um uh than chat
GPT but you can you can use one of these
Transformers and if you look at the the
um uh the post I made that there's the
actual Transformer is there and you can
you can play with an important language
um but anyways if you if you give that
Transformer this sequence here and you
say what comes next it says okay uh well
54 probability that there's a closed
paren there based on oh it's training
data was a randomly selected collection
of correct open close open close
parenthesis
um uh sequences
it has a little bit of a goof here
because it says with .0838 probability
this is the end of the sequence which
would of course be grammatically
incorrect because there's no close for
this there's for the for the open
parentheses here
if um
uh if we give something which is
correctly uh closing then it says okay
great there's a 34 probability this is
the end of the sequence there were no
further opens here it has a little bit
of a goof here because it says 15
probability there's a closed parenthesis
that should occur here which can't
possibly be right because if we put a
closed parenthesis here it doesn't have
a corresponding open parenthesis it's
not grammatically correct but anyways
this gives a sense of what it takes for
one of these Transformer Nets we can
look inside this Transformer net we can
see sort of what it took to learn this
very simple grammar chat GPT is learning
the much more complicated grammar of
English it's actually easier probably to
learn the grammar of English because
there's so many clues in the actual
words that are used to how they're
grammatically put together and there's
so many things that we humans wouldn't
even notice as wrong
in some sense of wrong because they're
they're kind of just what we do but in
this more austere case of just this sort
of mathematically defined parenthesis
language we do notice so if we just give
it a bunch of open paren open brand Etc
and we ask it what's the highest
probability continuation you'll see it
does pretty good up to this point and
then it starts losing it and it's kind
of a little bit like what would happen
with humans you know we can tell at some
point here that by just by eye that
these are correctly closed it becomes
more difficult to tell that when we get
out here and it becomes more difficult
for the for the network to tell that too
and this is a typical feature of these
neural Nets that with these sort of
shallow questions of oh you just have
you know you can just see this block of
things you see another block of things
it does fine when it has to go to to
much greater depth it's it doesn't work
so well for a sort of regular computer
that can do loops and things inside it's
very easy to to figure out what's
happening here because you effectively
just count up the number of open Brands
count down the number of close Brands
and so on on by the way if you try this
in actual chat GPT it also it will
confidently assert that it's it's
matched parentheses but it will often be
wrong the larger parenthesis sequences
it has the exact same problem it's it's
a it fails at a slightly larger size but
it's still going to fail and that's just
a feature of of this kind of thing
so
uh well okay so one type of regularity
in language that chat GPD has learned is
syntactic grammar
um another type of regularity there's
there's one more that that you can
readily identify and that's logic
and what is logic well originally when
logic was in was invented you know by
Aristotle so far as we know you know
what Aristotle did was effectively a bit
like a machine Learning System he looked
at lots of examples of rhetoric lots of
example speeches people gave he said
what are some forms of argument that
appear repeatedly if somebody says you
know uh something like people might have
said you know all men Immortals Socrates
is a man therefore Socrates is Mortal
um all all X's are y
um uh
Z is a is a is an X therefore Z is a y
um the uh uh that that logic is taking
sort of forms of of of of language and
saying these are patterns that are
repeated possible patterns in these in
these uh pieces of language that are
meaningful sequences and originally in
so logistic logic which is what
Aristotle originally invented it really
was very language based and people would
memorize you know Middle Ages people
would memorize these forms of syllogism
Barbara syllogism the celerant syllogism
and so on which were just these these
patterns of of word usage where you
could substitute in a different word for
Socrates but it was still that same
pattern that same structure so that was
that was that's kind of another form of
regularity and when chat GPT is says
it's oh it's it's figuring things out
well part of what's figuring out is it
knows so logistic logic because it's
seen a zillion examples just like
Aristotle the presumably seen a bunch of
examples when he invented logic he'd
seen a bunch of examples of this
sentence follows this sentence in this
way and so it can it's going to do that
too and it says what's the statistical
thing that's going to happen based on
based on the web
um and so so that's um
uh so by the way when logic developed by
the 1800s when people like Bool were
getting into the picture and making
formal logic
um it was no longer just these patterns
boom it's a pattern that looks like this
it was more this thing you could build
up many many layers of structure and you
could build you know very complicated
logical Expressions where the whole
thing was deeply nested and of course
our computers today are based on those
deeply nested logical Expressions chat
GPT doesn't stand a chance of of
decoding what's going on with one of
those deeply nested kind of mathematical
computational style Boolean Expressions
but it does well at this kind of
Aristotle level kind of um uh you know
structure of of sort of templated
structure of logic
okay well I wanted to talk just for a
little bit and then we should wrap up
here and I can try and answer some
questions
um the uh uh about kind of so what are
the regularities that Chachi PT has
discovered in this thing that we do
which is language and all the thinking
that goes on around around language
and I don't know the answer to this I
have some ideas about what's going on
I'll just you know give it a little bit
of a tour we talked about kind of
meaning space the sort of space of of
how words arrange in in some how you can
arrange words in some kind of meaning
space and we can we can kind of see how
words arrange these are different parts
of speech for a given word there may be
different places in meaning space where
different instances of that word occur
this is the word Crane and this is
different sentences there are two
obvious meanings of crane you know the
bird and the the and the Machine and
they sort of break up in meaning the
space where they are we can look at the
sort of structure of meaning space
another thing we can ask is is meaning
space like physical space is it the case
that there are parallel lines in meaning
space are there things where we can go
from place a to place B and we and then
in parallel we transport to new places
well so we can ask you know if we have
analogies is it the case that we can go
you know from woman to man from Queen to
King that those are sort of parallel
parts and meaning space the answer is
well maybe a bit not very convincingly
that's really the question in in space
in physical space this is the question
whether this is like flat space it's
like if we have things moving in flat
space you know
um
Newton's first law says if the thing is
not acted on by a force it'll just keep
going in a straight line well then we
have gravity and we can represent
Gravity by talking about the curvature
of space here this question is when we
go from uh you know ear to here I to C
those are sort of uh we're we're moving
in a certain direction in meaning space
and in a sense the question of whether
these things correspond to whether we
can do this kind of parallel transport
idea is something like how flat is
meaning space how much effective gravity
is there in meaning space or something
like that meaning space is probably not
something that's represented in terms of
the kinds of things that physical spaces
represented in terms of but that's a
question
so now when it comes to the operation of
tractor BT we can think about how is it
moving around in meaning space it's got
its prompt you know the best thing about
AI is is it's is its ability to okay
um and uh
that's the prompt moving around in
meaning space effectively and then what
chat apt does is it it continues that by
continuing to move in meaning space and
so the question is is there something
like a semantic law of motion an analog
of of kind of the laws of motion that we
have in physical space in the meaning
space of of Concepts words something
where we can say okay if it's gone if
it's moved around this way it's like
it's got momentum in this direction and
meaning space it's going to keep going
in that mean space it's nothing like
that simple but the question is what are
how do we think about how do we
represent kind of um the the the sort of
the the process of going through meaning
space
well we can start looking at that we can
say for example the different possible
continuations that we get the best thing
about ai's ability to and then what's
the next word well we can look at this
kind of fan of different directions that
it could go in meaning space at that
point and we can kind of see there's
some there's some direction in meaning
space it tends to go in that direction
it's not going all the way over here at
least not with high probability
okay well if we keep going we can kind
of just see sort of how that fan
develops as we go further out as as we
continue that sentence and we can kind
of this is kind of like our motion and
meaning space kind of question
and
you know I don't know what this exactly
means yet but this is kind of what it
looks like what the trajectory and
meaning space as chat GPT tries to
continue a sentence looks like the green
is the is the actual thing it shows I
think this is a zero temperature case
and the the gray things are the other
things that were lower probability cases
so that's that's some
that's kind of what um uh that's some of
you if we want to look at we don't want
to want to do natural science on chat
gbt and say what did it discover what
did it discover about how language is
put together one possibility is that
there are these sort of semantic laws of
motion that describe sort of how meaning
how you move through the space of
meanings as you add words into it into a
piece of text
I think a slightly different way to
think about this is in terms of what one
could cause semantic grammar so
syntactic grammar is just about you know
nouns verbs things like that parts of
speech things of that kind but we can
also ask is there a generalization of
that that is sort of more semantic that
doesn't just look at that has finer
gradations and just saying it's a noun
it's a verb and says oh well that verb
means motion and when we put this noun
together with this noun that's a thing
you can move together with this motion
word it does this we we kind of have
buckets of meaning that are finer
gradations than just parts of speech but
not necessarily individual words is
there a kind of a semantic grammar that
we can identify that is kind of this
construction kit for how we put together
not just sentences that are
grammatically correct that are
syntactically grammatically correct but
sentences which are somehow semantically
correct
now that that um I I strongly think this
is possible and it's sort of what
Aristotle was going for he even talks
about categories of of um uh sort of
semantic categories and things like this
he talks about a variety of things he
does it in a in a way that's based on
the fact that it was two thousand years
ago and we didn't know about computers
and we didn't know about a lot of kinds
of formal things that we know about now
uh strangely enough the amount of work
that's been done trying to make kind of
a semantic grammar in the last 2000
years has been rather small it's there
was a bit of an effort in the 1600s with
people like leibniz with his
characteristica universalis and various
other people trying to make what they
call philosophical languages uh sort of
language word independent ways of of
describing meaning and then their more
recent efforts but they've tended to be
fairly specific fairly based on
Linguistics
um and uh fairly based on the details of
structure of human language and so on
um and I think this the this uh this
idea that you can kind of have a
semantic grammar is is a
and that that's what's sort of being
discovered is that there are these rules
that go beyond that are just rules for
how you put together a a meaningful
sentence now you know you can get a
meaningful sentence could be something
like the elephant flew to the moon
does that sentence mean something sure
it means something it has a perfectly we
can conjure up an image of what that
means has it happened in the world no it
hasn't happened so far as we know
um and uh so there's a but you know
could it be in a story could it be in a
fictional World absolutely
so this thing about this sort of
semantic grammar will allow you to
allows you to put together things which
are somehow which are sort of um
uh meaningful things to describe about
the world
um the question of whether they are
realized in the world or have been
realized in the world is a separate
question
but in any case the um the thing that um
uh
that
is
to me interesting about this is it's
it's something I've long thought about
because I've spent a large part of my
life building a computational language
uh well from language
um system that is an effort to represent
the world computationally so to speak to
take the things that we know about about
chemicals or lines or or images or
whatever else and have a computational
representation for all those things and
have a computational language which
knows how all those things work it knows
how to compute the distance between two
cities it knows all of those kinds of
things and in in um and so this is I've
been spending the last four decades or
so trying to find a way to represent
things in the world in this
computational fashion so that you can
then compute uh uh you can then compute
things about those things uh in an
explicit computational way
it's something where uh and we've been
very successful at being able to do that
in a sense the story of modern science
is a story of being able to formalize
lots of kinds of things in the world and
we're kind of leveraging that in our
computational language to be able to
formalize things in the world to compute
things about how they'll work
now the um uh one feature of that
Computing about how things work is that
inevitably some of those computations
are deep computations they're
computations that something like a chat
GPT can't possibly do
and in a sense there's sort of a a
difference between the things that are
the kind of the the um
the sort of shallow computations that
you can learn from examples in something
like a chat GPT that you can say this
piece of language that I saw on the web
here is you know statistically uh I can
sort of fit that in in this place just
fitting together these sort of puzzle
pieces of language is a very different
thing from taking the world and actually
representing it in some truly sort of
formal way computationally so that you
can compute things about how the world
works it's kind of like well back before
people had kind of thought of this idea
of formal formalism maybe 400 years ago
or more
um you know everything that anybody
figured out was just you think about it
in terms of language in terms of words
in terms of sort of immediate human
thinking
um what what then sort of came in with
with mathematical science at first and
then computation was this idea of
formalizing things and getting these
much deeper uh sort of ways to deduce
what happens and and thing I've figured
out about 30 40 years ago now was was
this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility this idea that there
really are things in the world where to
compute what's going to happen you have
no choice but to follow all those
computational steps you can't just jump
to the end and say I know what's going
to happen it's a shallow kind of thing
and so you know when we look at
something like chat GPT there are
certain kinds of things it can do by
sort of matching together matching these
pieces of language there are other kinds
of things it's not going to be able to
do it's not going to be able to do sort
of the mathematical computation the the
kind of the the thing which requires an
actual computational representation of
the world
for those things like us humans it's
kind of a used tools type type situation
and very conveniently our Wolfram Alpha
system that uh um used in a bunch of
intelligent assistance and so on is uh
has this picture that it's using a wolf
and language computational language
underneath but it actually takes natural
language input so it's actually able to
take the natural language that is
produced by a chat GPT for example take
that and then turn that into
computational language do a computation
work out the results get the right
answer feed that back to chat GPT and
then it can talk sense so to speak
rather than just following sort of the
statistics of words on the web so it's a
way of you know by by allowing but you
can get sort of The Best of Both Worlds
by having something where you have this
sort of flow of of language
um as well as as something where you
have the sort of depth of computation by
having chat gbt use wolf from Alpha as a
tool and I wrote a bunch of stuff about
that and all kinds of things are
happening with that
um but uh
the thing that um
you know talking about what did chat GPT
discover
I think the thing it discovered is there
is a semantic grammar to a lot of things
there is a way to represent uh using
sort of computational Primitives lots of
things that we talk about in in text and
in our computational language we've got
representations of lots of kinds of
things whether it's Foods or chemicals
or or stars or whatever else
but when it comes to something like I'm
going to eat a piece of chocolate
we have a great representation of the
piece of chocolate we know all its
nutrition properties we know everything
about it
um but we don't have a good
representation yet of I'm going to eat
the I'm going to eat part well I think
chat GPT has shown us is that it's very
plausible to get sort of this semantic
grammar of how one has these pieces of
of representing these sort of lumps of
meaning in language and I think what's
going to happen and I've been interested
in doing this for a long time I think
this is now finally the impetus to
really uh really roll up on sleeves and
do it
um it's a it's a it's a somewhat
complicated project for a variety of
reasons not least but you have to make
these kind of uh uh well you you have it
has to be you have to make sort of this
process of Designing a language is
something I happen to have been doing
for 40 years designing our computational
language this is a language design
problem and those are to my mind those
are actually the the single most
concentrated intellectually difficult
thing that I know is this problem of
language design so this is sort of a
generalization of that but I think chat
GPT has kind of shown us what you know I
didn't know how hard it was going to be
I'm now convinced it's doable also to
speak
so what what does this um uh
you know you might ask the question you
know people might have said okay look
you know we we've seen neural Nets that
do speech to text we've seen neural
let's do image identification now we've
seen neural Nets that can write essays
surely if we have a big enough neural
net it can do everything
well not the neural Nets are the kind we
have so far that have the training
structure that they have so far not on
their own they will not be able to do
these irreducible computations now these
irreducible computations are not easy
for us humans either you know when it
comes to doing piece of math or worse if
somebody says here's a program run this
program in your head good luck you know
very few people can do that
um it um
it's something where there is a a
difference between what is sort of
immediate and easy for us humans and
what is sort of computationally possible
now another question is maybe we don't
care about the things that aren't easy
for humans it's turned out that we built
an awful lot of good technology over the
last few centuries based on what amounts
to a much deeper level we haven't really
in our technology we're not actually
going even that far into irreducible
computation but going far enough that
it's beyond what we humans can readily
do but what we can do with kind of the
neural Nets that exist today
um so I think the uh that that's the
kind of the the thing to understand that
there's a there's a certain set of
things what's what's happening in chat
GPT is it's kind of taking the average
of the web plus books and so on and it's
saying you know I'm going to fit things
together based on that and that's how
it's writing its essays and it's and
when it is deducing things when it's
doing logic things like that what it's
doing is it's doing logic like the way
Aristotle discovered logic it's figuring
out oh there's a pattern of words that
looks like this and it tends to follow
it like that because that's what I've
seen in in a hundred thousand examples
on the web
um so that that's that's kind of what
it's doing and it it kind of that gives
us some sense of what what it's going to
be able to do and I think the most
important thing it's able to do is it's
a form of user interface you know we can
get I might get something where I know
oh what really matters is three bullet
points
but if I'm going to communicate that to
somebody else they're really not going
to understand my three bullet points
they need wrapping around that they need
something which is a whole essay
describing you know that that's the
human interface so to speak it's just
like you could have you know the raw
bits or something and that wouldn't be
useful to us humans we have to wrap it
in a human like in a sort of human
compatible way and language is sort of
our richest human compatible medium and
what what chat gbt is doing is it's able
to I think what the the way to think
about it is it's providing this
interface that is well it is just it's
generating pieces of language that are
consistent but if you feed it specific
things that it will talk about so to
speak then it's kind of wrapping the the
specifics with this interface that
corresponds to kind of flowing human
language all right I went on much longer
than I intended
um and uh uh I see there are a bunch of
questions here and I'm going to go from
um and to try and address some of these
as a question from antipasts or
constructed languages like Esperanto
more amenable to semantic grammar AI
approach very good very interesting
question
so I think the one that I was
experimenting with was the smallest of
the constructed languages a language
called tokipona that has only 130 words
in it
um it is not a language that allows one
to express you know everything one might
want to express but it's a good kind of
uh uh Small Talk type language a small
language for doing small talk so to
speak but it expresses a bunch of decent
ideas and so I was I was I was going to
look at yes that it's a good clue again
to semantic grammar that there are these
small constructed languages it also
helps
um I think well I also think that
probably the largest the constructed
language is ethical is another uh
interesting uh Source it's a language
which is trying to pull in all of the
kind of language structures from all the
all-known languages in some first
approximation
um the
that's some
um uh yeah that that's that yes so I
think the answer is that yes I think
they're a good uh stimulus or um for
thinking about semantic grammar in a
sense when people were trying to do this
back in the 1600s they're very confused
about many things but you know
I one gives them a lot of they've gone a
long way given that it was the 1600s
they were confused about things like
whether the actual letters that were
written as you wrote The Language
mattered and how that was you know uh
more so than the than the structure of
things but but uh there was the
beginning of that um uh that kind of
idea
um
okay I'm going to take these from the
envelope I want to go back to some of
these others
um
okay Tori is asking how come on study
what's the best way of prompting chat
GPT could a semantic Lord motion be
helpful
undoubtedly yes I don't know the answer
to that I think it's a good question and
I don't really know
um the uh
um you know I think
um
yeah I don't know
uh Albert is asking is the 4000 token
limit analogous to working memory but
accessing larger memory be increasing
the token limits or increasing such
capabilities reinforcement learning
well I think that the the token limits
that exist right now uh are you know if
you want to have a coherent essay and
you want it to know what it was talking
about back in that early part of the
essay you better have enough tokens in
that are being fed into the neural net
every time it it gets a new token if it
just doesn't know what it was talking
about if it forgot what it was talking
about 5000 tokens ago it may be saying
totally silly things now because it
didn't know what was there before so in
some sense it's like it's I don't think
it's I don't think it's like our short
working memory but I think
um you know it's kind of like you Ramble
On I ramble on a lot you know talking
about things and like I might have
forgotten half an hour later that I
talked about that already I might be
telling the same story again I hope I
don't do that I don't think I do that
too badly
um but but you know that that's a
question of what that that's the kind of
thing that happens with this token limit
um
let's see let me go back to some of the
questions that were asked earlier here
um
okay uh Aaron was asking talking more
about the tension between super
intelligence and computational
irreducibility how far can llm
intelligence go I think I talked a
little bit about that I think this
question
oh boy this is this is kind of
complicated I mean so
this question about
okay
the the universe the world is full of
computational irreducibility that's it's
full of situations where we know the
underlying rules but we run them as a
computation and you can't shortcut the
steps
what what we've discovered from our
physics project is it looks like the
very lowest level of space-time works
just that way in fact just earlier today
saw a lovely
um uh work
um about uh
um doing practical simulation of space
times and things using using those ideas
and very much supporting again this it's
really computationally irreducible at
the lowest level just like in a in
something like a gas the molecules are
bouncing around in this computationally
irreducible way what we humans do is we
sample sort of aspects of the universe
that have enough reducibility that we
can predict enough that we can kind of
go about our lives like we don't pay
attention to all those individual gas
molecules bouncing around we only pay
attention to the aggregate of the
pressure of the gas or whatever else we
don't pay attention to all the atoms of
space we only pay attention to the fact
that there's this thing that we can
think of as more or less continuous
space so our story has been a story of
finding slices of reducibility slices
places where we can predict things about
the universe there's a lot about the
universe we cannot predict we don't know
and if our existence depended on those
things if we had not found kind of these
these slices of reducibility uh we
wouldn't we wouldn't be able to have a
coherent existence of the kind that we
do
so if you ask sort of where do you go
with that well there are they're an
infinite collection there's an infinite
kind of web of pieces of computational
reducibility there's sort of an infinite
set of things to discover about that we
have discovered some of them as we
advance in our science and with our
technology for for things we get to
explore more of that kind of web of
reducibility but that's that's really
the issue now the problem is that the
way that we humans kind of react to that
is we have ways to describe what what we
can describe we have it we have words
that describe things that are common in
our world we have a word for a camera we
have a word for a chair those kinds of
things we don't have words for things
which have not yet been common in our
world and you know when we look at the
innards of Chachi PT it's got all kinds
of stuff going on in it maybe some of
those things happen quite quite often
but we don't have words for those we
don't have a way we haven't yet found a
way to describe them when we look at the
natural world we've there are things
that we've seen repeatedly in the actual
world we have words to describe them
we've built up this kind of descriptive
layer for for talking about things but
one of the things that happens is
the if we kind of jump out to somewhere
else in the son of Universe of possible
computations
there may be pieces of reducibility
there but we don't have words to
describe those things we only have we
know about the things that are near us
so to speak and so and gradually a
science advances
um we get to expand the domain that we
can talk about so to speak our
everything advances we get to have more
words we get to be able to talk about
more things
um but in a sense to have something
which operates
it's this gradual process of us sort of
societally in a sense learning more
Concepts we kind of can exchange
Concepts we can build on those Concepts
and so on but if you throw us out into
some other place in what I call the
rouliad the uh the space of all possible
computational processes if you throw us
out into an arbitrary place there we
will be completely confused because
there will be things we can tell there
are actual computations going on here
there are things happening there's even
pieces of reducibility but we don't we
don't relate to those things
um so it's kind of like imagine that you
were um
you know you're here now
um and you're you know chronically
Frozen for 500 years and you wake up
again and there's all these other things
in the world and it's hard to reorient
um for all those other things without
having seen the intermediate steps
um and I think that that when you talk
about kind of what where can you go from
what we have now how can you sort of add
more you're basically intelligence is
all about these kind of uh pieces of
reducibility these ways to jump ahead
and not just say it's uh what we what we
think of as sort of human-like
intelligence is about those kinds of
things and I think the um
um uh you know so what's the vision of
what will happen you know when when the
world is full of AIS sort of interesting
because actually we've seen it before I
mean when the world is full of AIS and
they're doing all these things and
there's all this computational
irreducibility they're all these pockets
of reducibility that we don't have
access to because we haven't sort of uh
you know incrementally got to that point
what what's going to be happening is
there's all this stuff happening among
the AIS and it's happening in this layer
that we don't understand it's already
happening and plenty of places on the
web and you know bidding for ads or
showing you content on the web whatever
there's a layer of AI that's happening
that we don't understand particularly
well we have a very clear model for that
which is nature nature is full of things
going on that are often computationally
reducible but we don't understand what
we've been able to do is to carve out an
existence so to speak that is coherent
for us even though there's all this
computational reducibility going on
we've got these little niches with
respect to nature which which are
convenient for us as as humans so to
speak and I think it's sort of the same
thing with the the AI world as it
becomes like the natural world and it
becomes sort of not immediately
comprehensible to us that's
um we are we are kind of um
um we're you know our view of it has to
be oh that that's just you know the
operation of nature that's just
something I'm not going to understand oh
that's just the operation of the AI is
not going to understand that there's
this piece that we've actually managed
to humanize that we can understand so
that's that's a little bit of the the
thought about um about how that develops
uh in other words you know you can say
I'm going to throw you out to some
random place in the rouliad there's
incredible computations happening it's
like great that's nice I've spent a
bunch of my life studying those kinds of
things but pulling them back reeling
them back into something which has sort
of direct human understandability is is
a difficult thing
uh
Aaron is asking more of a business
question about about
um
Google and the Transformer architecture
um and why
you know
it's been a very interesting thing that
the
sort of
neural Nets with this
small field very fragmented for many
many years and then suddenly things
started to work in 2012 and a lot of
what worked and what was really worked
on was done in a small number of large
tech companies and some not so large
tech companies
um and uh uh it's sort of a different
picture of where Innovation is happening
than has existed in other fields and
it's it's kind of interesting it's kind
of potentially a model of what will
happen in other places but but you know
it's always complicated what um what
causes one group to do this another
group to do that and they're the
entrepreneurial folk who are smaller and
more agile and and they're
but the folks who have more the more
resources and so on it's always
complicated
um
okay Nicola was asking do you think the
pre-training a large biological inspired
language model might be feasible in the
future
I don't know
um I think that the the figuring out how
to train something that is
you know we don't know what parts of the
biology are important one of the one of
the incredibly important things we just
learned is that probably there's not
much more to brains that really matters
for their information processing than
the the neurons and their connections
and so on it could have been the case
that every molecule has you know some
Quantum process that's going on and
that's where thinking really happens but
it doesn't seem to be the case because
this this Pinnacle of kind of our sort
of thinking powers of being able to
write the long essays and so on it's it
seems like that can be done with just a
bunch of neurons with weights now which
other parts of biology are important
like uh uh you know uh actually Terrace
just wrote this paper talking about how
there are more backwards going uh uh
neural Connections in brains than
forwards going ones so in that sense it
looks like maybe maybe we missed the
point with these feed forward networks
that something like chat GPT basically
is and that the feedback is is uh you
know is really important but we don't
yet we haven't yet really got the right
idealized model of that I do think that
the uh you know the sort of the the the
what's the next McCulloch pets type
thing what's the next sort of simple
meta model of of this is important I
also think that there's probably a bunch
of essential mathematical structure to
learn about General mathematical
structure to learn
um no that's you know I was interested
in your own that's back around 1980
um and I kind of was trying to simplify
simplify simplify models of things and
neural Nets I went I went past them
because they weren't simple enough for
me they had all these different weights
and all these different network
architectures and so on and I ended up
studying cellular automata
um and and generalizations of that where
where you know you have something where
the everything is much simpler there are
no real numbers there are no no
arbitrary connections there are no this
that and the other things but what what
matters and what doesn't um we just
don't know that yeah
uh
uh Paul is asking what about a five
senses multimodal model to actually
ground the system in the real world with
real human-like experience I think that
will be important and that will no doubt
happen and you know you'll be more
human-like look this chat gbt is pretty
human-like when it comes to text because
by golly it just read a large fraction
of the text that we humans at least
publicly wrote
um and but it didn't no it hasn't had
the experience of walking upstairs and
doing you know doing this or that thing
and so it's not going to be very
human-like when it comes to those sorts
of things if it has those experiences
then then I think we get to um uh you
know then that that will be interesting
um
okay someone's commenting on the fact
that I should do the same kind of
description for image generation uh
generated AI for images
um the uh the thing that I like to think
about there is I think that's that's one
of our first moments of communication
with an alien intelligence in other
words we
in some sense we're talking to the
generative AI in English words or
whatever and it's going into its alien
mind so to speak and plucking out the
stuff that is these images and so on
it's it's less so you know with chat GPT
what the output is something that is
already intended to be very human it's
human language with with
um
a an image generation system it's more
uh it's really it's producing something
which has to be somewhat recognizable to
us it's not a random bunch of pixels
it's something that resonates with
things we know but in a sense it can be
it can be more completely creative in
what it's showing us and in a sense as
one tries to sort of uh you know
navigate around its space of what it's
going to show us it feels a lot like
kind of you're communicating with an
alien intelligence and it's kind of uh
it's kind of showing you things about
how it thinks about things by saying oh
you said those words I'm going to do
this and so on I mean I I have to say
that I'm I'm if if we can't you know the
other examples of alien intelligence is
that we have all around that planet are
lots of lots of Critters from the
citations on so to speak
um that uh and I have to believe that if
we could correlate kind of the
experiences of those Critters cats dogs
you know
cockatoos whatever else
um and the vocalizations that they have
and so on and we could you know that
that it's it's talk to the animals time
so to speak I think that's a that feels
like uh that that's you know the the
kinds of things we've learned from chat
gbt about the structure of human
language I am quite certain that if
there's any linguistic structure for
other for other animals it'll be similar
because it's one of the lessons of
biology is you know there are fewer
ideas than you think the you know these
things that we have have precursors in
biology long on ago we may have made
Innovations in language it's kind of the
key innovation of our species but
whatever is there had precursors in in
other organisms and and that's what um
and and the fact that we now have this
much better way of kind of teasing out a
model for for language in in humans
means we should be able to do that
elsewhere as well
uh
okay David is saying chat gpt's
developers seem committed to injecting
uh sort of political
curtailments into the code
um because uh to avoid it talking about
controversial topics how's that done
it's done through this reinforcement
learning
um uh stage I think maybe there's also
some actual you know if it's starting to
use these words just just stop it type
things I think maybe that's being done a
little bit more with maybe with Bing
than it is with with chat GPT at this
point
um I think that the um uh I have to say
the one thing that I consider a you know
so far as I know chat GPT is a G-rated
you know thing
and that's achievement in its own right
that it doesn't um maybe I shouldn't say
that because probably maybe they're a
horrible counter examples to that but I
think that was a
um you know in terms of one of the
things that happens is well you have a
bunch of humans and they are giving it
this training and those humans have
opinions and they will have you know
there'll be this kind of politics or
that kind of politics or they'll believe
in this or that or the other and they
are uh you know whether purposefully or
not they're you know they're going to
impose those opinions because there is
no you know the opinionist what you're
doing when you tell chat GPT that essay
is good that essay isn't good you know
at some level that's an opinion now that
opinion may or may not be colored into
something that is uh about you know
politics or something like that but it's
it's sort of inevitable that you have
that I mean I have to say you know
something I've thought about a little
bit in connection with with General sort
of uh AI injection into sort of the
things we see in the world like social
media content and so on I tend to think
that the right way to solve this is to
say okay let's have multiple you know
chat Bots or whatever and they are in
effect trained with different criteria
by different groups under different
banners so to speak and you know you get
to pick the banner of chat bot that you
want to be using and and then then
you're happy because you're not seeing
things that horrify you and so on and
and you can discuss you know whether you
want to pick the chat bot that that
accepts the most diverse views or
whether you want to you know that that's
a that's that sort of throws one back
into um
into kind of standard issues of
political philosophy and things like
this I mean I think the thing to realize
is that there is a there's sort of an
ethics
you know one wants to put ethics somehow
into what's going on but when one says
let's have the AIS you know do the
ethics it's like that's hopeless ethics
is a there is no sort of mathematically
definable perfect ethics ethics is a the
way humans want things to be and then
you have to choose you know well is it
the average ethics is it the you know
the ethics which makes only five percent
of the people unhappy is it this that
and the other these are old questions of
political philosophy that don't really
have so far as we know good answers and
but once thrown into those questions
there's no you know oh we'll get a
machine to do it and it'll be perfect it
won't happen because these are questions
that that aren't solvable for a machine
because they're questions that in a
sense come right from us these are I
mean the thing to realize about chat GPT
in general chat GPT is a mirror on us
it's taken what we wrote on the web so
to speak in a in in Aggregate and it's
reflecting that back to us so insofar as
it does goofy things and says goofy
things you know some that's really on us
I mean that's you know it's our sort of
it's It's the average
um kind of uh
uh the the the the sort of the average
web that we're we're seeing here
um
tenacious is asking about a particular
paper which I sounds interesting but I I
don't know about it
uh
let's see
up up soon here
um
okay tragath is was wondering how neural
net AI compares to other living
multicellular intelligence
uh plant roots
um
nerve Nets and things like jellyfish and
so on biofilms yeah well okay so
one of the big things that's come out of
a bunch of science that I've done is
this thing I call the principle of
computational equivalence which
essentially says that as soon as you
have a system that is not
computationally trivial it will
ultimately be equivalent in its
computational capabilities and that's an
important thing when you talk about
computational irreducibility because
computational irreducibility arises
because that you've got a system doing
its computation there's no system you
can't expect there to be all other
systems will just be equivalent in their
computational sophistication you can't
expect a super system that's going to
jump ahead and just say oh you went
through all these computational steps
but I can jump ahead and just get to the
answer
now a question that is a really good
question is when we look at okay
one of the things that is characteristic
of our Consciousness for example
relative to all the computational
irreducibility in the universe is
the fact that we have coherent
Consciousness is a consequence of the
fact that we are two things it seems to
me we are computationally bounded we're
not capable of looking at all those
molecules bouncing around we only see
various aggregate effects point one and
point two that we are uh we believe that
we are persistent in time we believe we
have a persistent thread of of existence
Through Time turns out big fact of of
our last few years for me is that the
big facts of physics uh general
relativity theory of gravity quantum
mechanics and statistical mechanics the
second world thermodynamics law of Entry
increase all three of those big theories
of physics that arose in the 20th
century all three of those can be
derived from knowing that we human
observers are noticing those laws and we
human observers have those two
characteristics I just mentioned I I
consider this a a very important
beautiful sort of profound result about
kind of the fact that we observe the
physics we observe because we are
observers of the kind that we are now
interesting question I suppose is when
we so we are limited we are
computationally limited things and the
Very fact that we observe physics the
way we observe physics is a consequence
of those computational limitations so
the question is how similar are the
computational limitations in these other
kinds of systems in a sense the fungus
as Observer so to speak how similar is
that kind of Observer to a human
Observer and in terms of sort of what
computational capabilities it has and so
on my guess is it's pretty similar and
in fact one of my next projects is a
thing I'm calling Observer Theory which
is kind of a general theory of uh of
kinds of observers that you can have of
things and so maybe we'll learn
something from that but it's a it's a
very interesting question
uh Dugan is commenting
um
uh chat GPT can be improved using an
automated fact checking system like an
adversarial Network for instance
um
could one basically could one train chat
gbt with Wolfram Alpha and have it get
better the answer is surely up to a
point but then it will it will lose it
just like it does with parentheses I
mean there's a certain with a network of
that architecture there's a certain set
of things one can learn but one cannot
learn what is computationally
irreducible I mean it's in other words
you can learn the common cases but
there'll always be surprises they'll
always be unexpected things that you can
only get to by just explicitly doing
those computations
Bob is asking can track GPT play a
text-based adventure game I bet it can I
don't know I haven't seen anybody try
that but I bet it can't
um
okay there's a question here from
software uh aside from being trained on
a huge Corpus what is it about gpt3 that
makes it so good at language I think I
tried to talk about that a bit about the
fact that we it's it's um uh that
there's you know there's regularity in
language I think the the particulars of
the Transformer architecture of this
kind of looking back on sequences and
things that's been helpful in refining
the way that you can train it
um and that that seems to be important
uh
let's see
um
Victoria's asking could future impact
scores help us understand GPT better
well so what that what that's about is
when you run a neural net you can kind
of uh you can say
uh sort of
how much
what was the
how much did some particular feature
affect the output that the neural net
gave
trappy GPT is just a really pretty
complicated thing I mean I started
digging around trying to understand sort
of what as a natural scientist you know
I'm like I couldn't do sort of
Neuroscience with actual brains because
I'm a hundred times thousand times too
squeamish for that but you know I can
dig around inside an artificial brain
and I started trying to do that and it's
it's it's difficult I mean I I I I
didn't look at feature impact scores I I
think one could
um
the uh
Okay so
um but by the way I mean I'm I'm amused
by these questions because because I I
can kind of you know I can still tell
you guys are not
Bots I think
and um uh
let's see
um Ron is asking about implications like
I have to work late tonight what does
that mean
um yeah absolutely chat GPT is learning
stuff like that because because it's
seen you know a bunch of text that says
I have to work work late tonight
um so I can't do this it's seen examples
of that it's kind of doing the Aristotle
again it's just seeing this uh you know
these patterns of language and that's
what it's learning from so to speak
um so yes these things we might say how
do we think about that formally oh it
seems kind of complicated to us but that
pattern of language has has occurred
before all right last last thing perhaps
um
uh okay Albert is asking do you think
humans learn efficiently because they're
born with the right networks to learn
language more easily or is there some
difference
I think it is important the architecture
of the brain undoubtedly is important I
mean uh you know my impression is that
there are uh you know it's it's a
matchup for the neuroscientists to go
and find out now that we know that
certain things can be made to work with
artificial neural Nets did the actual
brain discover those things too and the
answer will be often yes
I mean just like there are things we
probably have learned from you know the
flight of drones or the flight of planes
that we can go back and say oh did we
did biology actually already have that
idea
um I think that the um uh there are
undoubtedly features of human language
which depend on aspects of the brain I
mean like for example one you know
talking to Terry zanovski you know we're
talking about the um
the loop between the basal ganglia and
the cortex
and the possibility that you know the
outer loop of track GPT is a little bit
like that Loop and it's kind of like I'm
turning things over in my mind one might
say maybe that's actually a loop of data
going around this literal loop from one
part of the brain to another maybe maybe
not but sometimes those those sayings
have a habit of of being more true than
you think and maybe the reason that when
we think about things we have these
certain time frames when you think about
things the certain times between when
words come out and so on maybe those
times are literally associated with the
amount of time it takes for signals to
propagate through some number of layers
in our in our uh in in our brains and I
think that in that sense if that's the
case there will be features of language
which are yes we've got this brain
architecture we're going to have this
these features of language and insofar
as language evolves as so far as it's
it's adaptively worthwhile to have a
different form of language that is
optimized by having some different form
of brain structure that's what will have
been driven by by natural selection and
so on
um I mean I think you know there are
aspects of language like we know if you
you know we tend to remember five chunks
you know chunks of five so to speak
things at a time and we know that if we
try and give a sentence which has more
and more and more deeper deeper deeper
sub Clauses we lose it after some point
and that's presumably a hardware
limitation of our brains
uh okay Dave is asking this is a good
last question how difficult will it be
for individuals to train something like
a personal chat GPT that learns to
behave more and more like a clone of the
user I think it I don't know
um I'm gonna try it
I have a lot of training data as I
mentioned you know 50 million typed
words a type yeah typed words for
example uh from me
um and uh
um my guess is I mean I know somebody
tried to train a um an earlier gpt3 on
on stuff of mine wasn't I didn't think
it was terribly good when I read once
trained for other people I thought they
were pretty decent when I looked at one
train for myself because I kind of know
myself better than I know anybody else I
think
um the uh uh you know it didn't ring
true so to speak
um and uh
but I I do think that that will be a uh
you know being able to write emails like
I write emails it'll do a decent job of
that I suspect uh you know I would like
to believe that uh you know one still as
an as a human one still has an edge
because in a sense one knows what the
goals are the the you know know this
system its goal is to complete English
text and you know the bigger picture of
what's going on is not going to be part
of what it has except insofar as it
learns the aggregate bigger picture from
just reading lots of text so uh you know
but but I I do think it'll be an
interesting I I I expect that you know
I as a person who gets a lot of email
some of which is fairly easy to answer
in principle that you know maybe my
botch will be able to answer the easiest
stuff for me all right that's probably a
good place to to wrap this up
um
thanks for joining me and uh uh
I would like to say that for those
interested in more technical details uh
some of the folks in our machine
learning group are going to be doing
some more detailed technical webinars
about uh about this material and uh
really going into how you would
um you know how you build these things
from scratch and so on
um and uh what some of the more more
detail about what's happening uh
actually is but I should wrap up here
for now and um thanks for joining me and
uh bye for now